everybody i think we need to start now
um so welcome to the development control
meeting today my name's kathy guthrie
and i'm the chairman today i hope
um may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room
by following the fire exit signs and
meet on the ipswich town football club
training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images in sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you have
finished now before i do introductions
can people hear me now
it's just that we do seem to be having a
bit of difficulty with the sound system
and i do apologize so if members when
they speak can we just sort of shout at
the microphone for the
purpose of the
sound
so the introductions we have in duprey
our legal officer we have john pateman g
senior planning officer we have robert
carmichael um
what do we call you
governance officer but he keeps me on
track and then we have
mark a planning officer and we have
mandy who's steering the internet we
have more people from the council who
will be presenting cases down here we
have our ward members
and we have ladies and gentlemen over
the back who may have
offered representation supporters
applicants agents parish councils you
have a three minute to speak and we have
technology to cover that but most
importantly we have our members of the
committee here who will debate and
decide on the applications before us
so
there we are with that
and now we move on to the agenda
apologies for absence and substitutions
uh we don't have any apologies chair but
we are aware that council carter is
running slightly late so he'll join the
meeting when we get to the um for
whichever item we join that he arrives
for
and he will be able to vote when he's
heard a whole application so we've got a
short one coming up i'm going to give
you the order of play anyway is that in
order
thank you
to receive any declarations of pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest by members
there are none
declarations of lobbying
i don't recall any i must admit on this
no
declarations of personal side visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of january 2020
and i'll take it in bulk unless there
are any
amendments to be made so that's pages 1
through 2 pages 10.
and if everybody's happy with that may i
sign hello don't worry
no no just get yourself settled we're
just doing the preliminaries
um
good morning councillor carter take your
time
so may i sign these during the meeting
yep
thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
so to receive notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
none received here
and for the schedule of planning
applications i'm afraid we have rejigged
them just a little bit
so if you want to make a note of it
we are now doing
7e which is number 1 on page 413
the second one will be seven a which
starts at page thirteen
the third one
will be seven b which starts at page
eighty
three the fourth one will be seven c
which starts at page one seven nine
the fifth one will be
seven f
which starts at four one three
and now i've got two at four one three i
don't know
actually
hang on and the sixth one is at two nine
nine but they're the order i might have
just given you the wrong number pages
hang on
for number five it starts at four four
nine i apologize that's the only one
that's out
so the order we're doing them in is thus
do you have any declarations of lobbying
pecuniary interest or site visits
and which lobbying which application
have you been lobbied on please
do you want to have a look at that and
let us know during the during the
meeting if you would please thank you
that's right
right so mark if you'd like to present
the first case please
thank you chair good morning everyone uh
council humphreys has in his hands two
um brick panel samples which um
spell out what we're looking at at the
moment it's
it's a scheme for 300 houses by hopkins
which got permission back in 2016
um and there was a very restrictive
condition number five which said that
all the materials had to match the
drawings it was an unusually restrictive
condition i think nowadays would have a
tail piece on the end which would say
unless otherwise agreed by discharge of
conditions so
we're contractually tied up into a bit
of a knot there and i just wanted your
okay that the bricks could change from
uh let's get this right around
okay from the renaissance red to the
athena
it's as simple as that i can show you uh
i can show you the site map if you want
i can show you where houses are etcetera
but um that that is it basically and i
hope you could speedily say that's fine
you have to go
i'm sorry yes of course yes that's the
presentation as it sounds
very much indeed
so do members have any questions
regarding that particularly
so we can move on from that so
[Applause]
so there's nobody from the parish
council there's no protector there's no
representation
and councillor john mathis chris smith
sorry chris smith sorry
chris smith would you like to come
forward let me just
morning thank you chairman thank you
councillors um as your officer has
indicated um this application is purely
to request a change of brick detail on
some of the plots as you'll see from the
report
there have been issues with us being
able to source
the the previously proposed brick
hence we've tried to choose a brick
that's as of the same quality and
as appearance as best we can that we are
able to source um hence the reason for
this application um that's all i want to
say chairman but i'm happy to take any
questions thank you do we have any
questions
no thank you very much thank you very
much if you'd like to return to your
seat
councillor matheson as the ward member
if you'd like to speak thank you
yes thank you chair i'm sure the um i'm
sure the parish council are right in
preferring the other brick but i i think
that given the overall impact of the
site
on the on the area that are changing
this one brick
um a bit it's 88 of the the 300 houses
we're not talking about the whole estate
in a different brick
um that really we
we need to agree to this and let them
get on with it
thank you very much any questions to the
ward member
no
in that case then from the chair i'll
actually propose the recommendation um i
would say when i built my house i was
asked what color brick i could have and
i was told any color brick you like as
long as it's red
so it's
it's a very appropriate color
so i propose it do i have a seconder
councillor norris thank you very much oh
thank you
yes i'm very happy to second the
recommendation and it's as per the
recommendation in our papers all those
in favor
thank you very much we are unanimous
thank you
so we move on to
lawn farm
warren lane orchid that's right isn't it
so mark if you'd like to present that
case to us thank you
can everybody hear me
thank you everyone this item was
deferred from the last um it was
development control a committee
because some of the information was
lacking so we're back again
the application is for
employment use at lawn farm
wool pit
the the larger map there shows the a14
going around to the south of the site
uh
and you can see the orange and and the
and the pink color which will come onto
a minute let's zoom in a bit
there we go
so you've got two um
pieces of land
which measure about five and a half
hectares between them
in between is a site that's already got
permission for employment
looking at constraints um although it's
disappeared amongst the hashing there
there is actually a
footpath which goes north to south for
the middle of the site
um and over to the
east
there are a couple of listed buildings
that's lawn farm and there's long
cottage down there so
those are the constraints
the proposal is the two islands of red
the blue line obviously spells out the
the largest site
and the proposed new employment land is
in those areas which i've shaded parcel
a and parcel b
now it's possible parcel lane might be
split up into two smaller ones that's
been shown on some drawings but all
we're considering today members is the
principle of employment on this site
with landscaping and access being
considered but the access to confirm is
an existing one anyway
also to note on this drawing is the
landscaping scheme which was agreed by
condition from an earlier permission
and was bolstered at the last committee
by members with
an amended
landscaping belt over to the west
so along here members secured a five
meter planting belt
this is new planting as well
this is a six meter planting belt
and there's a ten meter belt over there
that's already secured previously by
condition
so to clarify on the accesses there are
two existing vehicular accesses which
already have permission that which is
numbered number one
is officially at the moment just the
emergency access but it's built up to
adoptable standard to be a proper access
and it will become so as as the site
expands
access to is the main access at the
moment they're both in and out
the green access over to the right is
for cycles only onto warren lane
so to clarify this is the existing
permission
you can see the two buildings over on
the left the top one is already
built and occupied
by a company called precon
and the one below it is about to be
commenced
and the shaded area to the right has
outline permission and two weeks ago we
received the reserve matters application
for bacton transport
so on the site itself this is the precon
building
thanks
and precon a construction and building
supplies company
that's the adnac so i'm standing on
there looking towards a precon building
so obviously the
ground has been disturbed ready to go um
and there they are a valve specialist
and that's looking across to the backton
site as i say we've got the application
in for that so um hopefully be able to
determine that soon enough
of interest is the scaffolding company
landmark scaffolding which is on warren
lane
we recently had an appeal on that site
the applicant wished to have housing
there
and the appeal was dismissed
because the inspector was concerned that
it could jeopardize the future
employment
interests of lawn farm itself so we've
got recent appeal which does help us
the other point that was raised from our
heritage officer was he was concerned
about the the setting of the listed
building and identified harm
and left it to
officers to weigh up the public benefit
um i've circled the main part the listed
building there
and it gives you an indication of the
relationship between the listed building
and
the site which is um
which is shown by the trees basically
over to the left
rmr policy e8 does support the expansion
of existing employment sites which this
now is
um provided things are satisfied such as
the transport network um landscaping
issues etc our landscaping
consultant has agreed to the landscaping
scheme
and the highway authority is not
objected
so in principle we have
a few reasons to turn this away it's
also an allocated site in the joint
local plan so i would ask that members
can consider to
approve this application thank you
thank you very much any questions for
the officer councillor norris thank you
thank you yes just a very quick question
could the officer clarify on page 14
whether the application site is or isn't
within the neighborhood plan area
she's saying is true is not
my understanding is because it's in the
parish of wall pit that it's in the
neighborhood plan area um i could be
wrong but the neighborhood plan itself
is such an early stage it's it's very
limited weight anyway
thank you
and councillor mansell you had a
question please uh thank you yes um i
noticed on page 21 um the added uh
sections of the report um
it mentions that some of the vehicles
going in and out of the site are tracked
i i'm just interested to know if that
information
will be publicly available
there's no um there's no provision
within the existing permission for it to
be made publicly available um if you
wanted something from this permission to
do that then you can ask that as a
condition but as it stands there is not
and also maybe the applicant can give us
some information on that too thank you
uh yes councillor matherson
um yeah i did i did ask the um
planning policy team to
see if they could justify the difference
um
between
the um parishes on the one hand and the
um economic development
um point on the other hand um
regarding whether the yes who are you
asking the question to because we
haven't got the planning policy team
here
no well what i wanted to say was that
the
robert hobbs has provided
a response to me do you want to do that
in debate rather than question and
answer now because this isn't the
officer might read it out but no matter
if you find it we can we can
look at it individually
sorry we have the economic development
officer here which i should have said
she is here to answer the questions on
the economic side forgive me for not
saying earlier sorry i wasn't aware that
you were here well would that help you
counselor matheson
and can you answer the question that
he's asking or not
all my questions robert's response if
yeah that's
so basically um who is the response to
is it just individually to council
it was yes yeah well i think that needs
to come out in the debate rather than
well we don't have sight of that we
haven't got sight of it here so
okay we'll have a we'll have a listen to
it
oh sorry
oh am i i'm on that
this
one
no it's that one
sorry
um
and it's just closed
it was basically that the um
the emerging plan
recognized the need for flexibility and
assessment of employment lands and also
for employment uses and recognized the
importance of the a14 in the strategic
growth
going forward i think that's reflected
in the report anyway yeah okay that was
it in a nutshell
thank you so can we move on then please
and we have julia ewans from the parish
council please if you would
good
morning the parish councils of woolpit
and elmswell have been against this
development from the beginning
to allow further expansion would be in
would be inconsistent with the cases
made previously against ad hoc
intrusions into the countryside
employment sites such as this should not
be encouraged it is away from public
transport and ill-served by the highway
network with its reliance on
single-track country lane access to
elmswell
weatherdon and woolpit
this site can be accessed from the east
bound a14 at junction 47a
however on leaving the site traffic is
expected to travel east on the old berry
road through hawley new street and
rejoin the a14 at junction 49
few car drivers will make a round trip
of 11 or 12 miles
to get from the site back to the a14
route
road route into woolpit
they will use the narrow warren lane and
wood lane
and heath road routes
um if they were going to woolpit
and perhaps the even narrower kiln lane
to get back to the roundabout at the
foot of elmswell hill
if we are lucky vans and lorries will
not attempt these routes
we should not have to rely on luck
an hgv ban should be placed on all these
small roads
together with the imposition of other
measures to discourage workers private
vehicles using these roads
the traffic experts report states that
the road past the site has spare
capacity this may be the case but it
will not be the preferred route away
from the site
what are the proposals for mitigation to
allow safe vehicular passage and
encourage walking
and cycling
by the future workforce resident in
local villages
if this site is to expand
could a footbridge not be provided over
the a-14 to give pedestrian and cycling
access
the parish councillors of warped urge
rejection of this proposal thank you
thank you very much hindi
two members have questions for the
parish council
thank you may return to your seat thank
you
we don't have an objector or a supporter
we have
excuse me bethan hague
who is either the applicant or agent
thank you
good morning chair members
my name is bethan hague and i'm from
boya i'm representing the applicant
woolpit business parks limited they are
a family-run business all of whom live
in the local area mostly in woolpit
itself
this application seeks outline consent
for a mixture of b1 b2 and b8 uses
at this stage the proposals seek to
confirm the principle of the development
alongside details relating to access and
landscaping
details of layout scale and appearance
will be submitted at a reserve matters
stage
as part of this the applicant will
continue to work with the council to
deliver a high quality scheme which is
respectful of the surrounding area
the principle of unemployment use in
this location has already been
established
this would form an extension to the
existing lawn farm business park where a
hybrid consent was previously granted
for three units which is under
construction
occupiers for these units have already
been confirmed and a reserve matters
application has also been submitted for
the for the third unit on behalf of
bacton transport
the wider site also forms part of an
emerging allocation for employment land
as set out in your emerging joint local
plan
the business park is becoming a
recognized economic hub within
mid-suffolk given its location along the
strategic road network
as a result of its success to date my
client has received a number of
inquiries from potential end users
which has ultimately driven this
application before you today
they have advised my client that there
is no suitable alternative employment
land available along the a14 in the
vicinity to meet their specific
requirements in the necessary time
scales
this has also been confirmed by the
council's economic development officer
who has stated that there is an unmet
employment need within the district
this proposal provides a real
opportunity to expand on and support
much needed economic growth and job
opportunities within the district to
ensure that mid-suffolk retains its
position as a place where people want to
live and work
the proposed development has received no
statutory consulting objections in
relation to highways ecology
environmental health drainage and
landscape
the council's heritage officers consider
there to be a low to medium level of
less than substantial harm on lawn farm
and in accordance with the nppf this is
outweighed by the significant economic
benefits of the scheme which should be
afforded considerable weight
overall this proposal is in accordance
with local and national policy and it
represents a sustainable development
which will deliver jobs and accessible
land to meet the area's employment needs
the officer's recommendation for
approval is welcomed which confirms that
the principle of developing the site for
employment purposes is suitable and
acceptable
and it is respectfully requested that
you support the officer's recommendation
and approve this application
thank you very much for your time
thank you very much
do members have questions for the
applicant
uh yes sarah quick question yes well i
just wanted to follow up my my previous
question about the data obtained from
the vehicle tracking movements from the
site and whether
uh either would you be willing to make
this publicly available or available to
the parish councils of elmswater moorpit
because it would be of interest to them
i would imagine
thank you and i can definitely speak to
to pre-con that are currently using
using that information and can go back
to you on that just to explain that so
the vehicles are tracked and the reason
for this is to ensure that the
businesses um are using the um the
workplace or travel plan and things that
that's in place at the minute and that
they're conforming to it which is part
of a condition on the on the hybrid and
which we'd imagine would also be a
similar condition placed on this
application thank you
um i have a question um i used to live
in woolpit and i know will pit elmsville
the area extremely well
um can you just put up a plan of of the
the road system there um is it intended
that some of these lorries would go down
warren lane towards elmswell and cut
through to elmswell
uh no not sure they would be continuing
to go on to the next junction i mean the
old day 45 yes
and so is is that a sort of um
an expectation or a requirement
and that is a requirement as part of the
um travel plan that's in place and
that's another reason for why the
vehicles attract to ensure that they
conform with this
thanks thank you for that that's helpful
um yes councillor humphreys
i'm sure thank you it's pretty much the
same vein i've looked at the map and
i've looked at the satellite image
there's lots to talk a single track road
but just for my memory
i'm pretty sure i've driven down it and
run down it now the old a14 isn't single
track is it
um the old road to the north of the site
no no it's not thank you
thank you if you'd like to return to
your seat
thank you
and we now have
councillor mansell and councillor geek
and you can fight over who goes first
thank you very much uh uh thank you um
uh now i i'm i'm i i'm not in a position
to support the expansion of the lawn
farm business park in woolpit uh as it's
already been mentioned by wool pit
parish council
the highway network is is not really
sufficient uh in this area uh as has
already been said access to the site is
fine you come off the eastbound
carriageway of the a14 and you have
direct access to the site it is getting
back onto the a14 that is the issue any
eastbound traffic for the a14 yeah
that's going to go all the way along the
old a45 to top hill and join the a14
again if it wants to go westbound that
is an extra
four miles onto its route to go that way
so yes warren lane elmswell which is
which is a single track road does
already have a lorry ban
warren lane wool pit does not have a
lorry ban
so there is nothing legally to stop uh
bit large vehicles going that way um
although
it may not be the actual heavy vehicles
that is the issue it may be the uh
employees who have small cars and i i
mean there is one shed that is already
occupied
and it is noticeable that there is more
traffic turning down warren lane towards
the center of elmswell um to get back
onto the a14 now it either has to go
along kiln lane which is even narrower
than warren lane or it goes up to the
warren lane cross street junction which
is an accident hot spot anyway
so i would be very interested to make
sure that any travel plan is adhered to
because there is a definite increase in
traffic
along warren lane
now on the heritage and landscape issues
lawn farm which is adjacent to the site
is a listed building
it has already got
permission for three sheds uh
surrounding it um so you could argue
that having another three or four is not
going to make much difference but it the
lawn farm is going to be completely
dwarfed by these uh new big warehouses
the pre-con site that's already there
looks like a big site but it's it's the
the one that is now just gone in for
reserve matters is uh probably almost
three times the size of that they really
are big sheds um and one question that
we are regularly asked at parish council
meetings is why is it painted blue when
you are looking at the lawn farm from
warren lane wall pit
you are looking towards the site with
trees in the background so the blue
stands out against the trees now if
you're coming from elmsworld direction
as in the photograph yeah the blue goes
against the sky but if we're worried
about the impact on the listed building
i'm not convinced that blue was the
color it should be
so i i can't really support this
mainly on the traffic issues and there
are some concerns about the heritage of
lawn farm
any questions
i mean i can i just remind members that
appearance is not part of this
application
um
funnily enough i i hear loud and clear
what you say about the coloring and
funnily enough i actually would be happy
to promote the blue but where they've
gone wrong is they've put green at the
bottom and blue because if you go to
milton keynes you can see blue coming up
and blue coming up in blue coming up and
it actually works very well but i hear
your point but we can't really discuss
the appearance but um it's certainly
noted
so
one question i have
and just for clarity
is
your concern
is it the warren lane going to elmswell
and to wool pit that is your concern is
that your concern
yes i i mean i think the the shortest
route back to the a14 roundabout will be
down warren lane towards elmsol to the
bottom of the hill and then you do a
left turn
i know how you do it
that is the shortest route so that is
the i think the the way that a lot of
the employees in their private cars will
use um
they may depending on which direction
they're going yes they may end up in
wool pit as well but wool pit doesn't
have the roads towards woolpit don't
have any um lorry bands on them so you
could get larger vehicles going that way
the larger vehicles obviously can't go
down warren lane towards elmswell or
well so we we hope but it that there is
a lorry ban on that road so there is
some concern that some of the larger
vehicles may go through woolpit to get
back to the westbound a14
we you know depending on how the debate
goes i mean we could always ask highways
to put the restriction both ways um
which if the debate goes one way or the
other but
just a point so thank you for the
information
so counselor
do members have questions so first of
all councillor humphreys and then
councillor matheson thank you chair
thank you um one question one point
really um the question is
is there already industrial activity
close to long farm the heritage site
yes as you've seen on the plans i'm not
denying that there is one there is one
shed that has recently been constructed
and uh there are people working there
and there is the scaffolding firm which
has been i don't know how long the
scaffolding firm has been there thank
you i mean there is a point really you
said that it was an accident black spot
and i think you're referring to warren
lane in church lane at home as well with
a turn left
since that
employment started with the new the new
um shed just point clarity when did the
new shed or the new industry start
because the only accident has been there
according to the crash map won serious
in 2017
was three years ago so i wonder if it is
actually related and whether your point
is relevant i'm not saying that the the
accident has happened because of this
site at lawn farm i'm saying that
highways have already recognized that
that junction needs work doing to it
because there have been accidents there
in the past i i don't think the accident
was anything to do with lawn farm
thank you councillor matheson please
thank you yeah
are you saying that the the um
the route
that that i would take from this site
to to woolpit over
over the overbridge and then back into
woolpit
but there's no lorry band on those
that that option
no
that's not my word i think you're
talking about not to my knowledge there
there's no lori
no further question oh yeah cancer
carter
i'm not sure who to ask but would it be
possible to
ensure tracking on the employee
vehicles private vehicles can sure no
that's private information and that's
i was going to say um yeah private
rights liberties and so on i'm sure
you'd be appreciative of not invading
that
um right so if we're done on that any
further question do you have any
questions gentlemen no
councilor gee thank you
thank you chair um yes i'd like to start
by saying i agree with uh counselor
mansell and the comments made in writing
by amsoil and woolpit parish councils
and by hawley parish council and by mrs
ewins today um as councilor mansell said
at first sight it looks like this site
has good connectivity to the a14 but in
practice it's very hard to get back onto
the a14 when you're leaving the site the
recommended access to the a14 westbound
as as at the very least eight miles to
the journey is four miles out and it's
four miles back now this may not be a
severe highways issue but it is an
environmental issue and it's also an
issue that will stop people taking that
recommended route we can't stop commuter
traffic going up that narrow warren lane
to elmswell through those two already
problematic junctions in elmswell to the
a14 if they choose the
shorter but narrower kiln lane they get
to a very dangerous junction on the a14
slip road or as we've heard all vehicles
could go down warren lane south a wood
road to woolpit up heath road another
problematic road a lorry route at the
moment past woolpit school past wool pit
health center to the a14 now those who
work at the current location of orpik
business park on the outskirts of
woolpit they often walk into the village
to buy a sandwich or to do a bit of
shopping that is not possible here the
hundreds of workers here won't
contribute to the local economy and
they'll disadvantage it by driving
through it
on the point about the neighbourhood
plan it is within the area of woolpit's
neighborhood plan this is not at an
early stage it's going to be submitted
to the inspector in two days time and
this area has shown those key view it's
not shown as employment land in the
neighborhood plan employment is
supported providing that it's within the
capacity of the existing infrastructure
and road layout and we've heard of the
problems of that it's supported provided
it does not encroach on gaps between the
main village of woolpit and one or more
of the outlying settlements this
development does encroach on these gaps
and has good access to the a14 avoiding
the village center and again we've seen
that access to the a14 will not avoid
the village centers of either elswell or
woolpit so none of the conditions in the
draft neighbourhood plan are fulfilled
by this site now wulpit is already the
large the third largest employment site
in the district so we welcome businesses
but in the right place and this isn't in
the right place and so i don't support
the application
questions for councillor geek
yes councillor humphreys
mum chair is it not true that there's an
excellent cafe called the stag cafe
which is about 200 meters from the site
and that
arguably would be where the
people that work there would probably go
for those snacks that you talked about
walking into wallpaper
they can if they want to go to a cafe
but we we find that the ones from the
woolpit business park attending not to
use the cafes in woolpit but
attending to go to the shops
any further questions
no
thank you very much indeed thank you
right and did you want to speak just to
a couple of points that you've both
raised thank you
uh just to
make some comments really on the policy
position because it's starting to get
muddled already and i wanted to make
sure it's clear to start with uh yes
the wallpaper neighborhood plan is
coming forward and we'll be going
for examination soon
at this time we give it little weight
on the basis that it hasn't gone through
that process we don't know what policies
will survive if i can put it that way
that process they may get changed
and so forth
the other thing of course is that
particular local
neighborhood plan which is part of the
development plan has to have general
conformity with the local plan
the district's local plan and the
district local plan
is interestingly in a state of flux
between two points one is the local plan
98 which has policies within it
e8 for example and others that would
support uh extensions of existing
employment sites as well as new
employment sites
we also then have the draft emerging
joint local plan which has allocated
this site lawn farm as a strategic
employment site
um now of course that has again little
weight so there's an interesting debate
on what way to give what policies
because there's a tug of war between
various aspects here
but i would perhaps advise you that they
are all generally in the right direction
to support this site overall as an
employment site an expansion of within
it
i think i'll probably leave it there but
i just want to make sure that people are
aware of these aspects i'm just
very briefly though just to pull up on
one point of the nppf which is the
government's national planning policy
framework uh which again also encourages
employment sites as you might expect
as it
encourages employer employment growth
but it does also talk about where you
have existing allocated sites and it is
found
by officers planning by the planning
authority that they are no longer
relevant that we should be looking at
alternative sites and uses for them
this has started to occur to some of mid
suffix sites because of the age of the
local plan 1998 and we've had some
allocations of employment sites around
stone market particularly that have now
had to come forward for housing and we
have justified that previously on the
basis of the nppf so there is a state of
flux over the amount of employment land
available uh which is why we've got the
employment of economic officer here who
is looking at the current position as we
go forward thank you
thank you for that
i just have a question actually of the
economic officer hello
we note on page 23 um that it says that
bacton transport is the intended
occupier do we know if they're
relinquishing their current
location
if that's the intention
or whether they will have a duel
my understanding is that they see they
they've been seeking a larger site for
some time so my expectation is that they
will
move okay it's only expectation right
thank you very much
thank you right we're open to debate now
so
who's going to start us off with that
then please
councillor mathison thank you yeah i i
i must say that the the overwhelming
thing that struck me about this is this
problem
of vehicles leaving to go west onto the
a14 and how they're going to get there
and um
so
you know with with that thought in mind
and
all right so
we're hearing about the vehicle tracking
and so on and i don't know quite what
penalties are imposed on on
drivers and companies whose lorries
don't
go the extra four miles to get onto the
a14 um but i think
you know intensifying
what's what's already there in the light
of that i've i do find that actually
quite difficult
and um in terms of
alternative sites and so on um the the
other point that i raised with with well
with the officer and the planning policy
and everybody was
the the idea that the
um the gateway 14 site which obviously
also has um
access to the
we'll have access to the a14 in both
directions um but that wasn't being
marketed i totally struggled with that
um because
it's it's been it's been an employment
site for for a lot of years already in
in policy terms
um so i do struggle with those those two
points
um i have to say councillor um i hear
what you say
but that's not relevant to planning
today we've got to look at what we're
looking at the sites and the marketing
of what's available now so we can't
bring in that debate we're looking at
the site here
um sorry just to clarify ultimately
you know different owners have all these
various industrial sites across the
district
they're
we can't really sit and judge how they
have marketed or not marketed those
sites and ultimately we have to deal
with this site on its own individual
merits
in terms of the proposal before us
but i do hear what you say point taken
yeah
who else would like to join the debate
please council of war boys thank you
i i find it quite difficult to find a
sort of balance point in this
i think serious concerns have been
raised about the um
infrastructure to be able to cope with
um
expansion of this
um industrial site
uh it is a bit i think we
seem to be in another chicken and next
situation where
you've got um
what looks like an appropriate site for
industrial development but it isn't
really supported
by the infrastructure where you've only
really got a clear access going
eastbound from the a14 even that is onto
a smallish lane
uh
i do take on board the need for um
employment and the need for employment
sites
near to the a14 and not scattering them
throughout the county but
in this case the the heritage team has
also raised serious concerns about the
ice
the successive
development and the impact on the
isolation of
lodge farm from the surrounding
agricultural area and to a lesser extent
uh
lawn cottage
and the site the other site of um across
the road from uh warren lane is a
a special landscape area the warren i
think it's woolpit wood
but you've got this um
further impact if you like into an
important landscape area it's it's it's
one of the major ones
that is bisected already by the a4 team
thank you
who else would like to speak councillor
gould thank you thanks so much and
on cancer warboy's
sort of way of looking at this is a
point of balance
between uh
concern and opportunity i i guess
for me i'm probably on the other side of
that point of balance
we understand the
importance of economic
growth the provision of jobs
to go along with the considerable
housing growth
that we're providing looking at the
application uh before us
the things that
the principal things that strike me are
one that we have a site
which
is adding to it's an established area of
of activity um
and in a sense i was struck looking at
the
the heritage assets there and the impact
has already been made by uh
by the development uh economic
development that's taking place
uh i see nothing i i hear
the uh the experience uh and the
predictions of the
of
of ward uh councillors but i'm also
looking at the highways assessment uh
that we have here which is uh
seems fairly um
unambiguous
to me so
i am i'm
kind of minded depending on how the
debate goes but at this point i'm i'm
minded uh towards uh
approval of the application thank you
thank you can we just have the the um
for the overall photograph that you had
that showed lawn farm
and
the site and i think there was some
it was more um
a view of the uh google sort of
did what's shown in the buildings it
shows that well not necessarily there
were some buildings already adjacent to
lawn lawn farm and and so on
let's keep going let's see where we get
to it keep going it was an actual visual
and that keep going
it was an aerial photographer above you
know that was okay right at the end yeah
there was a right that one yeah what
what what is um
in the top of the picture on the right
is that the site
what what that's landmark scaffolding so
the circle is around lawn farm the
farmhouse yeah to the north island which
historically was linked to it but is now
occupied by
landmark scaffolding so that is already
there that's already there yeah yeah
okay
right thank you i just thought we'd have
clarity on that thank you
um councillor humphreys
i'm sure thank you um
i get all the arguments actually both
sides and i sort of agree with some
someone you're signing someone this side
and
where where are we well
the land's already been allocated for
employment the inspector who turned down
the housing application actually said
this jeopardized employment
opportunities um the joint local plan
identifies this area as suitable for
employment and should be used for
employment and although it's got limited
weight that is some weight because it's
not zero so we've got to take that in
mind and the j and the local
neighborhood plan isn't mature enough to
have any weight as far as i understand
it
so we are where we are um
there's already employment going on in
that particular location according to
the crash map there's been no increase
in traffic accidents or incidents so i
based it on the evidence that actually
it's made no difference and when we talk
about sustainability of the location i'd
argue that you could cycle from
elmsworld or wool pit to this site so
that ticks all the boxes really because
you don't have to use a car but that's a
choice thing if you want to use a car
you can um the argument that it will
take four miles to join the a14 if
you're going eastbound or want to use
the old a14 is a very good argument on
environmental reasons but actually i
might want to go to felix stone so
that's a more direct route and would
actually shave off about half a mile so
there's no bend so technically i'd be
more environmentally minded to go along
the old a14 to join the a14 if i'm going
to felix stow or to the east or to
london because we don't know where this
transport is actually going to go with
its goods we don't know where the goods
coming into the location are coming from
so it's all subjective but the fact is
that it has got a decent road to the
north of the site which is the old a14
which is because i have driven along it
suitable for hdvs and that's proven
really because industry uses it already
and it's also suitable by normal cars i
don't see an issue with that and it
seems a suitable road for the for the
actual location if we go on to the core
policies policy cs11 i understand it's
2008 i get all that but it is the policy
we've got it talks about really
supporting employment in rural areas
enhancing employment that we've already
got and it also identifies as some of
the tables that businesses in the
woolpit business part that should be
encouraged and also along the a14
corridor now this is it's the a14
corridor is a suitable place for
industry and business why wouldn't you
have a business there and again as it's
already been built on already has
employment i just don't see any reason
mppf core policies sustainability any
reason why we can't actually move for
approval on this actual
application and because of that and i
have looked at everything and i have
listened to your arguments
i can't find any reason for not
approving it so therefore and i'll add
one more thing sorry elmswell and walpit
we talk about employment opportunities
this is an opportunity for local area
immediate local area wallpaper and
elmsworld to provide jobs which actually
we talk about the environmental
sustainability bit ticks another big box
because we don't have to travel to whip
switch berry segments london or wherever
else to find work surely that all works
and how can we argue against it
so with that in mind and the fact that i
can't find any reason to not approve
this i'd move for approval and therefore
i propose that we actually approve this
application
thank you very much for that councillor
humphreys first of all can i have i've
got everybody hands going up here uh
councillor caston then councillor carter
then councillor gould then councillor
norris i think that's got everybody down
so councillor casten
thank you very much chair and i agree
with the lot the councillor humphreys
has just said um we do need to be
flexible to um provide employment land
and we've heard that the demand is high
the existing permissions in place i
think
mean that the impact to heritage
is a lot less
um
than it um would be
the highways issues
so
i am i don't think um
i i don't think you should ever send
lorries down roads like warren lane
unless you absolutely have to um we we
sometimes do but as a matter of the
running of a business they shouldn't be
going down there um
it seems
with this there's three very sensible
routes to the site and one very bad well
one four mile detail so i think you got
to spread that four miles across the
other three very suitable and very
direct
accessors which
that that i'd like i'd like that to be
taken into consideration in it um i'm
minded to approve
this and um if you're looking for a
seconder for that
i'd like to second the um
councillor humphreys
thank you just before we move on and to
all the other
members
we mentioned earlier about
restrictive access down some of the
unsuitable routes
can we put an informative on if if the
proposer and secondary is
happy with that
because
you know clearly both councillors have
and and the parish council have
expressed concern
which would be i'm i'm in your hands
ultimately they can't do anything about
it so would we like a letter to the
highways authority to see if that could
be achieved should we should it be
minded to be approved we don't know yet
we're just in that stage would you as a
proposal be happy with that muncher i
wouldn't i think it would appease the
the parish councils and rightly so yeah
i think that'd be a really good move and
the second on that right and as a
secondary yes i think that would be a
very good idea okay thank you um so can
we move on um to councillor carter
please thank you very much
well unfortunately you just stole my
points
but
um i would like to say it's very um
very mindful that this current
administration has
business and growth in mind so it's
we can see the direction where this is
likely to be heading
uh but we have also
we have also
declared a climate emergency
yet we've yet to do anything in regards
to this sort of thing so i did wonder if
if the applicant was
agreeable if they could do an
environmental asset
asset reports uh and
to propose ways of actually mitigating
any further
um
uh transport
any further
that might be a if they could
look at
doing
anything to help mitigate the
environmental impact of
increased traffic
and i had a further point but for life
me i can't remember it
come to you in a minute i'm sure um
just one moment um sorry i've got
everybody talking at me even i can't do
it all at once um
it's gone sorry yes go on
um if i can just draw your attention to
the recommendation on page 24 you have
both sustainability measures and travel
plan
to be agreed
now if i recall the previous application
for the buildings that have already got
approval
and i do recall the debate that occurred
then
there was a discussion about the
sustainability measures there was a
discussion about encouragement of
electric charging points and so forth
i'm intrigued by obviously recent
government change of four in respect of
fuel and there are aspects around that
that obviously this business is going to
have to
consider in the next 10 years really
but ultimately we do have that in place
which would match the existing buildings
and i think it was quite a high spec at
the time i don't have it specifically to
hand but i do remember was it was it was
quite it was as good as we could do at
this po current policy position
thank you um i remember the electric
charging points did you remember your
point councillor
uh yes also in garden lecture charm
point so yes
yeah we're kind of on the same way
um i had just wanted to point out as
well uh regarding the
ragam neighborhood plan um i know that
we are as uh early well considering
those days to like might have been two
days before um review
um i would be mindful that
being a local plan that if they are
obviously more aware of issues than we
are as a
over overly so
i would
have to put more weight on a
neighborhood plan than i would a joint
local plan which has the
administrative
view so
that's where i'm thinking
but unfortunately it isn't made so we
can't have regard to it and we have to
look at it in the legal round am i
correct yeah i know i know where you're
coming from
yeah they they do form part of it
um well we've got some more before you
counselor matheson you've had a few goes
at the moment so let's have um
counsellor
gould i've got next and then councillor
norris
i'd i'd be delighted to give way to
council matheson especially as i was
going to say uh sikcon uh second the uh
proposal
council customs already done our
pleasure too well it's councillor norris
first and then councillor matheson again
so councillor norris if you would please
thank you yes uh without taking too much
of the committee's uh time um i think
partly my point of concern could you
speak up because i'm sure they can sorry
yes
my concerns basically relate to the
access back on the a14 for the heavy
traffic travelling um westwards uh the
recommendation on page 24
i noticed does include conditions uh
highway conditions and a travel plan
i'll just point out on page 37 the
response from highways england
in the middle paragraph of nxa
reads a system substantial proportion of
trips associated with the proposed
development will be via the a14 but the
local access arrangements could make it
somewhat problematic for those trips and
such trips could easily find themselves
on suitable local roads we would
therefore suggest the local signing and
routing arrangements will require
particular attention
will this be taken account of within the
travel plan mentioned in the control
well i think that's what's going to be
with our letter that we're going to do
was it not
part of that was also picked up in the
previous application and as the previous
application is in the middle of
construction that's still to come
forward so
it's it is in there
and quite rightly so actually
so um
oh yes councilman if you would
please
yeah i wanted to just check that the the
bullet point recommendation
sustainability measures we will actually
fully incorporate on page 18
um two thirds of the way down there is a
recommended condition in detail um is
that the one
that we are being hinted
it is going to appear yeah
and um
yeah i think i think the other the other
question i've got really is is about the
um
the the implementation of some of the
things
on the on the previous approvals of um
on you know on this
overall piece of land um
the you know surely that this if we've
asked for the signing as per highways
england that on the first one they
should be there by now it needs the site
is in use
and and in the same
exactly in the same vein actually i did
wonder at the uh the note which i saw
somewhere other uh or perhaps it was up
on the screen that the um the cycle
access
um on the main access to the land um is
yet to be implemented also i mean what
are we doing to actually make sure these
things are
done in a timely way separate matter for
a different day i've been informed but i
think we've had a good enough debate on
this particular application where we are
you can make a decision on it
but the cycleway is another time am i
correct
if there are enforceable matters that we
need to chase up then that is a separate
point that we can take away from this
meeting and go to our enforcement team
to explore
both points you made yes
right on the basis of i have a proposal
and a seconder
before i
just go to that vote
i do like to say that i have heard
everything that the ward members have
said
and their concerns i used to live in
woolpit and so i hope with what we've
been debating on what proposals are as
safeguards that will safeguard those
concerns so all those in favor please
vote
one two
three four five five and those against
two
two and abstention
thank you very much indeed
we should keep going quick
would members like a quick break please
and can we make it quick because we can
go ahead thank you
and we are moving on to
the land west of the former bacon
factory at elmswell
and that's on page 83 and daniel it's
over to you thank you thank you chad um
can everyone hear me at the back is that
okay
seems to be no one's complained um
this application um was previously
deferred it was previously heard on the
8th of january
um
it's made an outline it proposes 65
dwellings on the highlighted site
access is to be considered but
appearance layout scale and landscaping
all to come forward as a later
application called reserve matters
if we look at the constraints map we can
see um
the edge of elmswell
here into the south we've got the
railway line
running across the south of the site
here we've got grade 2 listed building
located here there's also a few
public rights of way running on both
sides of the roadway line and also
through this
site here
when it was previously heard it was
deferred for additional detail to come
forward on highways matters
details of alternative routes avoiding
the school road church or a junction
detail of the proposed footpath route
between
woolpit and elmswell
and also for some information to come
back on junction capacity
the report you've got in front of your
members
adds additional detail to that that was
previously seen
in sections four and five and the
additional materials provided for you in
bold
if we go now to
this slide it still shows the
application site edged in
red black line is the extent of the
previously approved site on the grampian
foods
site
that's built out and then we have the
various dots showing the various
amenities within 12 minutes walk
of the application site within elmsworld
itself
we come now to
additional information on the
alternative routes avoiding the junction
at school road which is
the one here and that route is shown
with the dashed blue line from the
application site
um
utilizing
alternative routes through elmsworld
just so you avoid
being caught up in traffic on on school
road there we've got an additional
route this way and we've got an
additional route through
here as well
they don't add a huge amount of time
onto average journey times at
peak hours
we're talking about half a minute and a
minute
average
we've got additional details showing the
footwear cycle path link proposed by
highways um this is the corner of school
road along here um we'd be coming up to
the railway line and then the site up
here
um so the idea is to take a footpath
cycle way
along this pink dotted line
down here
the
site in here
is allocated as part of the joint local
plan
allocations document within woolpit this
is the site that's to bring forward the
new primary school
in woolpit
so the the footpath link would come
around here
to here and would reach that site so
we'll be able to
provide a walking cycling rink of 1.9
miles between the two
we've then also got some further
information on alternative routes
going east
so
you could always utilize the other
alternative routes
shown within
the previous plan and join the a14
its junction here
or there are additional routes
here um which are
well known in use by by residents and
they're roughly equivalent
to the speed of
this route going past
um
church road school road um i just want
to draw members attention to the
information provided by the highways
authority within the table papers on
pages 13 and 14
which provides additional information
which i've summarized within the report
but that is the information direct from
the highways authority
themselves
in terms of their previous response
where they note that the junction at
school road and church road operates at
an rfc of 1.05
with the rfc being a fancy highways
engineer's term for whether the
junction's over capacity or under
capacity with one being over capacity
and anything under one being
under capacity um
they confirm that at present the
junction operates
with
capacity there is capacity on the
junction at present to take additional
development
um the 1.05 figure quoted in their
previous response is the capacity likely
at the junction by 2024
taking account of allocated growth
growth that's coming forward through the
draft joint local plan
and
includes what they term as a growth
factor which takes into account windfall
sites such as this as well
so the junction will be operating over
capacity at 2024
but that is on the assumption that we
have no further highways improvements to
that junction
given that the draft joint local plan
allocates sites
along this school road
stretch
here and here
both those sites are being charged with
looking to bring forward
um
both part of the footpath cycle way
and charged with bringing forward
improvements to the junction the
specific nature of those improvements
we're still negotiating with the the
applicants
and that's due to
issues with heritage
assets within that specific area
and how the road
the road infrastructure that furniture
would sit alongside those designated
heritage assets
if i pass back to youtube we can go over
any questions soon as we've
so your recommendation is of approval
your recommendation remains for approval
yes given the support we've had on
highways sorry thank you
right
members do you have questions for the
officer please councillor humphreys then
councillor madison thank you mancherry
it's just clarification really on what
were these specific items that the
councillors thought needed to be
addressed
for it to come back to us and the
question is have those specific
questions and points been addressed and
answered
um to satisfactory level
yes we've had additional information
back from the highways authority we've
also had additional information from the
applicants giving us details of those
alternative routes
i think so i think in terms of the
junction capacity highways are clear
that
at present the junction does not operate
at capacity
it would only operate at capacity where
development to go forward and no
mitigation to
to happen to that junction and it would
be operating over capacity sometime
around 2024
i think the fact that we have two
applications
with us at present that are looking to
address that
means that we can probably have some
confidence that we will have some
improvement to that junction in the near
future
i think that um part of the alternative
routes
show
okay it's not the most direct route
um i think going um eastbound towards
the a14
for some people within elmsworld those
will be preferred groups
there isn't too much difference
going westbound on the a14
there is a half a minute a minute
additional journey time
i don't think that is an unreasonable
addition to the length of journey and
individuals will make the decision for
themselves whether they are happy to sit
in the traffic or whether they prefer to
take an alternative route
i think the footpath route
we have details of that now we know
where it is going we know that
in terms of the
school road aspect we have two
applications there and highways will be
looking for them to bring forward part
of that route within
land and their ownership
we have the
large allocation lao95 and woolpit
that's bringing forward the primary
school and other allocations in in
woolpit that would be likely to um
be sought for contribution towards that
that link
um you know elmsworld and wool pit have
a well-established
relationship whereby some of the
facilities are in arms well some of the
facilities are mull pit
and there is an expectation that people
will travel between two villages
to make use of them provision of a of a
walking cycle route would be
of benefit such that we've got a more
accessible and a preferable option or a
more attractive option so that people
making that journey could choose to do
so by bike could do so to do so on on
foot if they were that way inclined
and
we know that the
highway authority are looking to bring
that forward
in the near future they refer to that
forming part of their um
draft local transport options plan
in looking into that that's formed of
two components there's a strategic plan
that runs from
over a period of 20 years
that runs from 2011 to 2031
and then the implementation of that
strategic plan is broken down into
five four year periods
it's the next four year period plan
that's in draft currently and it's
within the lifetime of that plan that
highways will be seeking to bring that
up bring that footway cycleway to
fruition
and that will be using a combination of
land
that is highways land so part of the
highways version is in their control
part of the land will be in third party
ownership as we just discussed and part
of the land would be coming forward from
sustrans
thank you and just before we move on
there are copious
comments in the report following the
deferral page 97 to 98
does give us all those additional things
which is as daniel's just outlined
and one of the questions i've had all
along is
what exactly is the improvement to the
cycle way and the footpath and the
roundabout
so that's something that i think we're
all keen
to know about
but also
on page
93 sorry to spring it before you other
people
it does say 2.4 the site further secures
land for potential delivery of a later
relief road is that for this site only
have i missed that or is that for
no so um if i go to the relief road
first and then we'll go to the
roundabout
in terms of the relief road i understand
that that's an ambition of the armswell
neighborhood plan so that would come
forward um as part of that so there is a
a piece of land left
from the neighbouring site that's to
provide connection to the relief road
part of this site is set aside so that
development on this side doesn't
prejudice that
that partly feeds into when we talk last
time members about the width of the
access
onto onto this site and part of that is
designed so that when a late relief
world comes in that will continue that
line through the village
in terms of the the detail of how how
highways are intending to cross the
roundabout
part of that will have to come through
the drafts local transport plan um
it's my understanding that what they'll
probably try and do is
individual crossing points on on the
spurs with dropped kerbs
um so that you're there
that's helpful it's just that it's keep
talking about it and we don't seem to
know much about it now that counselor
matheson and then um counselor cast and
then counselor norris i must write it
down or offer thank you yeah the the um
the cycle route that is
presumably
that slide went through quite quickly
but the um presumably that's going
through the the
junction that's potentially going to be
over capacity i wondered whether we've
got any detail of the treatment
of of the cycle route through that
junction
so at present no that's still to come
forward in in detail through that draft
local transport plan
um
it's my understanding that that part of
that route is being delivered on
third-party land
um so it's my understanding that part of
that route wouldn't utilize the junction
at all for the footwear
cycle where it would be separate to
the junction itself
so yeah you would you would make the
turn
i mean my
forgive me i'm not a highways engineer
um my
my understanding would be that we'd stay
on this side of school road and then
make the turn on to church road
we haven't got the details so we haven't
got
it's speculation at this point but we
know that the highway authority are
looking to bring that forward within the
next four years
councillor casten and then councillor
norris thank you
thank you chair
um you
told us that an
an improvement to the junction was being
negotiated at the moment
and um one of the
complications in that was a heritage
asset could you um explain how
complicated
that
is and
how easy to deliver that improvement
will be
um so
reference there was being made to an
application that i'm actually leading uh
which is on the school road itself and a
site for uh there's 105 or 106 i forgot
which one it is but it's
just over 100 houses
on the top corner on the allocation
within the draft local plan part of that
a provision will and it's a current
application at the moment pending
decision um will be the widening of
school road
with the cycle path
and it will have
junction improvements
being proposed and we have got a plan
for that that the highways authority
have agreed
the conversation has been around traffic
lights
ultimately if you put traffic lights on
that junction
those traffic lights in their
lighting and physicality will have a
direct bearing on the uh designated
heritage assets on that
quite close by
um
but of course in elms well uh forgive me
but you know these are quite important
historic buildings because it's it's the
in terms of where where our other
historic buildings are now as well this
is the main sort of flurry of them in
this in this sort of junction so it is
important to get that right and we are
being very conscious about what we call
furniture that includes traffic lights
to ensure that the detailing of that
is correct at this moment in time given
all the allocations all the applications
that we have
that we have knowledge of
um there's no requirement for those
traffic lights specifically and that is
a current agreement that is something
we've just got agreed with the highways
authority however beyond this one beyond
all the others that we know about if
anything else comes forward that debate
on whether there should be a traffic
light system at this junction will be
reopened no doubt but we're sort of
speculating a little bit on an
application that isn't before us
so i would possibly then say as a
sidetrack we need to go back to this
application and as this application
stands is ahead of all the others so
therefore
we're talking about the capacity as it
currently stands is is from a highway
point of view absolutely fine um doesn't
require traffic lights doesn't require
those improvements directly in
association with this application um
we have got provision for money towards
a cycle route i will urge members that
we don't actually have
much in support of policy
for that requirement
that is just a
that is a very tenuous link to the
burden of the development um you know
the wallpaper local plan doesn't mention
it in terms of a policy that we can hook
it onto even as a draft neighborhood
plan we don't have anything within the
actual
draft uh joint local plan either to my
understanding i'm thinking correct there
so
you know that is a benefit
that is being put forward by the
applicant
and therefore perhaps should be given
more weight in that context
thank you councillor casten
thank you
the
comments the response from
strategic planning policy on page 143
seems to be at odds with the
recommendation to grant outline planning
permission with conditions
item one policy position
the final sentences say that the
proposal is not encouraged or supported
community
sorry community the proposal would cause
impacts on infrastructure
and then item two the middle paragraph
says that the proposed development is
not part of the proposed site
allocations of the emerging joint local
plan
could the officer clarify the position
please
uh yes they're absolutely correct
ultimately they are um we've asked them
for policy consideration they are
looking at their intended joint local
plan in the future
this is not a site within that plan
however
right now
we don't have
much material weight to give to that
joint local plan because it's only got
little weight and we are in a position
that we have a local plan that is out of
date as far as its planning policies on
housing are concerned something we've
discussed many times before but
ultimately we have to consider
this as
on that basis that this is um we've got
a local plan that isn't in full
compliance with the nppf and therefore
we
you know have to look at what is the
demonstrated harm of this proposal
on that basis the balance is within your
report
and we have gone through the various
aspects of material planning
considerations highways and so on and we
cannot find demonstrational harm to seek
a refusal in this case
so given a current policy position that
is out of date in terms of housing
supply because we have a housing supply
yes but the policies that attached to
that are still regarded as out of date
that was established under the wall pit
appeal
we have to deal with it on its merits at
this moment in time policy clearly will
look at the future policy position which
is what they've clarified in that
comment
and here we are
thank you very much any further
questions no
right
we now move on to mr peter dao if you'd
like to come forward please thank you
thank you chair good morning
um
i'm going to deal with only one of the
three main factors and leave the rest to
ward members
who get allowances we don't
which is the highways issue
it has been well aired in the previous
application
which just happens to have the same
pinch points as as we're likely to
suffer here
the over capacity of this junction is
very well documented
there's some slight of hand evident
whereby highways have suddenly decided
it won't actually
be over capacity until 2024.
the developer admits its over capacity
the parish council commissioned two
professional surveys both of which
proved that it was over capacity
and it's significant that the
application as uh mr patemanji has said
the application registered for the 105
houses which will be before you very
soon
suggested traffic lights on church hill
now we took a degree of joy in thinking
that this has been abandoned as the
nonsense that it is
but it left us thinking what next
one of the
several mitigation schemes that have
come and gone was traffic lights this
application
seeks to square that circle
by simply saying
it could be considered that many drivers
will choose alternative routes
which poses a big question
we're pleased to see there's no
suggestion that everybody will turn left
go up ashfield road and via the country
lanes through norton
it's cheering that nobody's actually
suggesting that's sensible however
the main suggestion of accessing church
road through the village through new
road and cooks road
still uses the same junction
everybody will still have to drive
through the church road school road
junction to reach the roundabout
therefore the pressure on capacity will
still be there
uh there will be a lot more traffic on
church road if that's the way people
choose to go and down church hill
which seems like
a nice option until you look at the
build up of the traffic
that has chosen to come down school road
it's waiting to turn right past the arms
houses past the church
waiting to turn left in the only route
accessible for them into the village
are the hgvs from mr wilson
and
mr hudson now mr wilson has 26 hgvs
nine of them are so big
they require rear steer and they don't
they're not what you'd call
nimble
to turn left into school road is a wide
arc and a problem
if that junction is blocked by traffic
trying to turn right
because it can't get out because of all
the traffic which decided to go the
other way
we have the same problem as we have
identified before we will have gridlock
mr dao you're on your three minutes
please
um but i'd like to take back to the
residence then if i may
um one of two things
if it's overloaded
um
the voluntary re-routing is not going to
work
therefore in light of the harm that
would ensue i'd like to report that
members have refused the application
do you have any questions for mr dao
please
no
thank you very much indeed thank you
we don't have an objector or a supporter
but we have mr jeff armstrong with chris
stock who's some highways consultant i
presume
i'm not sure you've only got three
minutes so i don't know if
you're going to split it or what thank
you very much
thank you very much good morning chad
good morning members
um my name is jeff armstrong from
armstrong rig planning and i've been the
agent for the planning application
at the last planning committee members
chose to defer the decision to the
application proposals to allow for
additional information to be provided
with respect to off-site mitigation
measures and clarification of the
alternative routes available from the
development onto church road
the details of which the officer has
gone through with you earlier on today
this information has now been provided
and serves to help demonstrate the
proposals are acceptable
in highway terms and offers a
sustainable location to meet housing
needs
i would therefore ask that you accept
the officer's recommendation and grant
planning permission
both myself and my colleague chris stack
my right are happy to answer any
questions from the committee myself on
planning and chris on highways thank you
very much
thank you very much
members do you have any questions at all
no thank you very much if you'd like to
return to your seats thank you we now
move on to the ward members and we've
got councillor mansell and councillor
geek and you can i believe it's
councillor geek's turn first
to have
your discussion thank you very much
thank you chair um
i would like to start off by saying that
uh mr down has put his case extremely
well and i agree with everything that he
says and i'd uh like to
add uh something specifically about the
primary school
i mean essentially i feel i can't
support the principle of development on
this site because of those
infrastructures
infrastructure issues and the primary
school is one of them we've got extra
information on pages 96 and 97 but we're
still told on page 89 that the elmsworld
primary school expansion project will
not be able to deal with pupils arising
from this proposed development as
existing permissions have absorbed this
additional capacity
page 96 paragraph 4.1 still talks about
how there's a primary school within a
12-minute walk and this is still
completely irrelevant as the children
from this site will not be able to be
accommodated at that primary school not
now and not in the future all of the
primary school children from this
development will need to be transported
outside the village with of course
massive knock-on effects for traffic
especially at those church
road junctions and school road and new
road junctions
the cycle and footpath between elm swan
and woolpit doesn't yet exist and i
think i'm right in saying that because
of this no wait can be put on it
as you've all noticed there's an awful
lot of unknowns still to be sorted out
in any case
talking about choice between driving and
cycling and walking the proposed route
is hilly and it's difficult it involves
going over the a14 on a bridge that's
shared with all those lorries
the choice of which means of transport
to use is therefore tilted significantly
in favor of the car at present and we
need to do something to make that the
right choice easier
also of relevance to families is the
provision of players and open spaces
i've got doubts about how both of these
will work in practice
particularly the play areas we hear on
page 102 paragraph 12.6 at play areas
with valued community assets and
represent a social planning benefit so
the significant weight attached to this
benefit but then on page 88 the public
realm team say that those open spaces
have only got very local value not
enough from at district council to adopt
them
um i'm really not sure why we're
bothering with with three tiny spaces
presumably all trying to recruit tiny
management committees
when most people i mean that's that's
adults that's teenagers and children
they like to meet up at a central place
to play with or chat with their friends
i think they're unlikely to be used much
and the money would be better spent
elsewhere and then lastly page 95
paragraph 3.14
talks about the employment that the
construction will provide
house building is a powerful stimulus
for growth it both creates and supports
many jobs while it is going on
well you all know these arguments so do
all sorts of other environmentally um
inappropriate things such as coal mining
we can't cover our countryside with more
and more development just because it
creates jobs while it's being built
these houses are going to stand for a
century or more the carbon emissions
caused by their building will be around
for even longer we have to look to the
future rather than concentrating on the
short term
so for those reasons i'd urge you not to
support it
thank you any questions for councillor
geek
councillor carter thank you
um yes um
thank you for that president's
presentation very we're well put
although it could have been slower for
me to go through the pages but um
um
i had
was going to ask regarding the
terrain you're saying how hilly it is
um we currently don't know about the
footpaths we don't know about the uh
how the access is going to be
uh regarding the uh
the
terrain forward footpath and for cycle
path we do not know whether or not the
um how
if the
um
how it's going to be lighted whether or
not it's going to be
traffic lights or there so
i do
how has there been any accessibility
reports to
elms or has there been a
um
has there been any
look to how it
affects
currently wheelchairs and uh
partially cited on the
route and is there any is there any
plans to look at the access
um and the terrain how it would affect
wheelchairs and
disabilities
um
yes that has been in the discussion
around the cycle path uh it's that is
all currently with sustrans who are
hoping to produce a feasibility report
by the end of march um but but we did at
meetings with them we have um pointed
out that it's not just cycle and
footpath
we must find a better way of describing
these things that's more inclusive
but all the options that sustrans have
looked at involve either a route that is
too steep for their current
recommendations and therefore they would
want to zigzag it which means that uh it
takes up very much more land it's much
more difficult to find the um the to
find the land for it and also it does
mean that some people
uh are likely to ignore those zigzags um
or that it's it's
it's steeper than it would normally
be recommended to be and a lot of people
are going to have to get off and walk um
and i'm hoping that the
wheelchair whether powered or
human-powered is is
that those aspects and needs are built
into that but we won't know totally
until the end of march but there are
just so many unknowns uh still
there um even and there will be even
with that report having been done it's
only a feasibility report that you know
it's difficult to say at the moment
thank you for that
um any further questions for councillor
geek
no
in that case then sarah if we can hear
from you please uh thank you um i too
would like to um uh offer my complete uh
agreement with both uh peter dao from
the parish council and my fellow ward
member
and i would also like to say that i
think council humphreys got the nail on
the head when he asked his question
about whether the issues had been fully
addressed
and he got the response that the officer
believed that they had well i'm sorry i
do not believe that they have been
addressed fully there are still way too
many unknowns about this application we
don't know whether the cycle path will
ever materialize we don't know whether
it's going to be suitable for all
we don't know what's going to happen
about the school we don't know whether
we're going to have traffic lights um at
the troublesome junction
and i would just like to to make a few
points about the added bits to the
report
regarding the education provision on
page 97
uh section 4.5 talks about the suffolk
county council bearing the cost of
transporting those kids to a school
outside the village
now dependent on another planning
application we may get a school site on
the north side of woolpit but it is not
the financial issue that is at stake
here it is the environmental issue
i mean even if there was a free bus from
woolpit to a new school from elmsville
to a new school in woolpit
would you as a parent put your four or
five-year-old on a bus to go to school
in woolpit i doubt it i think you would
drive that pupil to school through the
troublesome junction over the roundabout
creating an awful lot more pollution
creating parking issues at the new
school it is not as a sustainable
solution for the 21st century
neither will putting about a third of
the children from elmsworld to be
educated outside the village that will
split the community community there's
been no social cohesion it is not the
answer to this
to development along the a14 corridor um
regarding the the traffic issue um
you've heard from mr dao about the
traffic lights
which are troublesome we're told by some
of our planning officers that
there will be some mitigation but we
don't know what that mitigation is we
don't know whether it's going to be
acceptable the traffic the junction will
be over capacity in 2024
with no mitigation but we don't know if
there's ever going to be any mitigation
so how can we make a decision about
whether um
this development is is going to cause
trouble or not
um
now um i'd like to thank the officer for
putting some roots up on the slide um
and as has already been said the routes
to woolpit and the a14 westbound
do not avoid the church road school road
junction they just mean that you're
coming at it from a different direction
it is not going to
make any difference to the amount of
traffic that is at that junction they're
still going to go through it
the uh if you're going eastbound from
elmswell yes i can admit uh it's a it's
a route that
my family would use if we were going
towards ipswich and stone market we go
out along weatherton road we don't go
through the junction so fair enough
eastbound is not a problem it's the
westbound that's an issue
and we and we also see in the um
late papers we have the comment from the
planning um
the planning
the highways authority
just one other point that hasn't been
raised before regarding the level
crossing
we talk it talks about the amount of
delay
that could be caused by the level
crossing and then we have a comment from
highway saying that residents would time
their journeys to avoid the barrier
operations well at the present time you
never know when the train is coming
because it could be late delayed or
whatever so timing it is not the issue
i live north of the um level crossing
and yeah if i know that the barriers are
going to go down for a passenger train i
don't say i'm going to wait five minutes
i go the other way i go down the
unsuitable roads to norton or to whether
it's an upper town
people are not going to time their
journeys to avoid them they're going to
find alternative routes along unsuitable
roads
so i just still think
that we have far too many unknowns we
there are too many things that we don't
know too many ambiguities in the
highways issue that we cannot support
this application and i would urge you to
refuse it
sorry i do beg your pardon thank you for
that sarah um i just asked the officer
to pick up on a few points before i come
to questions to you which might help
some of the questions
um i totally agree there are a number of
unknowns however they're not relevant to
this application
um the footpath the lights the junction
improvements they are not a requirement
or directly required as a consequence of
this application
the application has provided a
contribution towards the footpath
improvements but there's no actual plan
for that footpath there's no proposal in
place for that that contribution i think
it's fifty thousand pound
is in place should it be required or can
be used if it can't be used i think it's
within 10 years it will go back to the
applicant it is a gesture of betterment
um ultimately it is not a requirement
for the burden of this development
directly and i do actually question if
it's needed at all
in terms of the school
yes the uh there is a plan for a new
school in woolpit
ultimately the education authority are
looking at the educational arrangements
of both wallpit and elmswell
they have no actual objection
before us in respect to this application
i would also point out there is an
unknown in terms of the education
question we do know what the numbers
of pupils might be across both villages
we don't actually know what the parents
choice might be in terms of which school
they send their children because
ultimately parents choice is available
these days it's not a pure catchment
system
um we also have an issue that you have
a kind of delay this is why you have
public transport laid on and paid for by
the applicant for the first five years
because you have different catchments i
can use the word catchment
ratios of kids in one school that may be
coming from woolpit and kids in
woolpit coming from elmsworld
if you provide capacity or a new school
in one of the other places those ratios
will change but it takes at least five
years for that to change
because the kids that are in the
existing schools at the moment need to
get through the system and get up to the
next school so ultimately we don't
actually know what the ratio is at the
moment with both of those schools are
where the kids are actually coming from
at the moment this is why you have a
five-year plan of transport costs
because it allows for that transitional
period
to take place
but like i said in the end we're not the
high we're not the highways authority
we're not the educational authority and
from an officer point of view from both
of those authorities we have no
objection before us thank you
[Music]
and just before i go on to questions uh
if i can indulge counselor mansell um
you're asking us to refuse this but what
defensible policies are you putting
forward um for us to do so bearing in
mind that we have gone to professionals
and the highways are saying one thing in
another so if you can give us some
policies and some help on that that are
defensible
then that would be interesting to hear
from you i i don't think i'm in a
position to provide the policies but as
you yourself have said on many planning
uh committee highways are a consultee
they are they they you know we are the
planning authority highways are only
consulting and sometimes i have my
doubts about their responses um because
i completely disagree with them but i'm
so so to cut you off basically you're
not offering us any help well i'm sorry
i think that highways are an issue we
the highways report does quite clearly
say that the junction will be over
capacity in 2024 but it doesn't really
offer any practical solution as to how
to deal with it saying drivers will find
an alternative route is not all right
you've made your points earlier thank
you i was just asking you for your
assistance to our members while we were
debating this so do you have questions
for councillor mansell
oh yes councillor carter i do beg you
pardon i saw you early
uh yes one comment is actually in
regards to the officer's comments uh
regards whether or not especially the
the unknowns are absolutely essential
and needed well we are looking here an
application for properties where people
will be put
for people to living in
more people living there's going to be
likely to be more people with different
accessibility needs
we need to know how they are going to be
getting from a to b if we are putting
more people in wheelchairs or partially
sighted are going on a route which will
be unsuitable for them to take to get
from a to b we are either going to be
stressing out the roads further by
necessity having to have vehicles to
attract transport to get from uh to get
out of their house if they're not going
to get through it
is this a question because we're not
quite into debate yes i didn't think
well
there's a question for we're just into
questions for the for the award members
at the moment okay the question is would
you
would you say that knowing the the
footpath would be an essential to
supporting this application at the
moment uh would you agree that a
a a further assessment via a disability
forum would be beneficial before we
could actually pass a a agreement on
this development
uh thank you yes i i do think that
having the the um
footway cycleway link to woolpit is an
essential part of this application and
yes i think it will need more study
to deal with
accessibility for all
and 50 000 pounds is not going to
deliver it
nor will another 50 000 from another
application
thank you for that right anything
please i think i need to discuss
something with um i mean
in respect of the football can we can we
just have an adjournment can we just
hold this for some legal information
please i do beg your pardon uh points
have been raised
sorry about that uh technical legal
issue which the officer will now proceed
to advise us a little further thank you
thank you
um i've asked for a quick conversation
where with our legal advisor in respect
of the footpath uh that's
a contribution towards
is uh
seeks to be secured as part of this
application
um there is no footpath scheme yet
it may come
but at the moment there isn't one
this is a the application before members
is purely to
reserve some money towards it
that is a gesture that is given by this
particular application
i am expressing my concern that in terms
of the strict legal tests of when we
secure a 106 agreement that i do not
find it in my opinion
necessary
or essential to mitigate the burden of
this particular development on the other
side of our line to the north of
elmsworld
i don't have any evidence to that effect
from any party that is necessary or
essential
so my proposal was to take it off
the the agenda in terms of part of the
recommendation
however
i am advised that if it is being offered
by the applicant
we could and can continue to secure it
on that basis alone
so it is still part of the
recommendation and i will leave it there
my concern here though is if we are
going to get into a finite detail of
what the footpath should look like how
accessible it is to all users what is
the finished design that is not
before us today
and equally if we go down the road of
considering this is a requirement of
this application that leads me to other
concerns and i may have to come back to
that should the debate go
that direction i think that's about
that's more i can say at this moment in
time
okay thank you
[Music]
right thank you so i think we've done
questions and lost the plot really
quick yeah we've just done questions so
we're now open to debate oh councillor
casten first one thank you
thank you very much chair um
so with the highways issue i can
i've got a reasonable idea of the weight
that i put to it because we we can't
deal with capacities that we haven't
reached yet
but
i i want i want to debate but also i'd
like a bit of clarification on these
primary school um capacity places there
isn't the um there isn't the capacity
for a third of the um
children
how much um weight does that carry in a
plan application and how often
do the
we have this situation where
children will go to a nearby village to
um
for primary school education
um it it happens across the district we
have similar situations in stone market
we had a recently similar situation in
first and as well um given the amount of
development that has obviously come
forward
there
so
the provision
to provide transport
is a known practice of the home of the
education authority it is what they do
to to
ensure that kids get to the right school
where there is capacity in this case
there's a contribution towards a new
primary school which would
be there for the future
because they do recognize that that
needs to come forward but
we have the
the wonderful thing about planning is
that we have to meet demand we don't
forecast and plan for the demand it's
always we're always catching up we're
not
putting in empty classrooms waiting for
them to be filled with kids it's the
other way around
[Music]
does that help
it does it's some it seems that the um
in the same way with the highways i i
won't
take into as much consideration before
it reaches capacity i've also got to be
aware that that school isn't built yet
and has not been provided in the same
way as the
the junction hasn't reached capacity for
this particular plan application just to
be
clear thank you who else would like to
councillor carter thank you
just a question for uh
of transport for school
as far as aware that was being cut or it
was under review for being cut for pro
for provision of um for transport
uh
to uh
uh
to the nearest school
we were looking at a
um an issue in need a market where
a school
where we was actually being funded for
one direction to one school but wasn't
it funding was not available for the
next the other way so
we just started query about regards
whether that funding is actually
available or how
transport would be made available for
the
schools schooling
sorry
i'm afraid i don't know what the county
policies are they are the county
policies in terms of what funding they
wish to give um in respect of this
application dan please help me if i if
you may we've got a pacific contribution
towards
a transport
for education
for
whatever time framework was five years
um yes we do yeah so we
in terms of this specific application
there is a funding specific for the
public sorry for the school transport
for uh kids generated by this
development that's secured as for wider
transportation issues um educational
transportation issues in elm's world i i
can't answer that i don't know what the
county policies are okay
sorry i can't reach my microphone my
thumb's playing that's right perhaps
counselor mathis and mike okay
thanks uh
chad i i find this a very vaccine uh
application um i've heard nothing about
um
the kind of virtue or benefits of the of
the application rather where we're
directed towards
uh whether there's a sufficiency of
reasons to uh to refuse it
it's not doesn't feel to be a happy
place so it's uh it's a quite familiar
uh
place first to be in um
i
i'm grateful and i think it council
knowledge is quite right in drawing our
attention to
um
the strategic planning policy um
contribution
which
um
talks about
which says the proposal was not
encouraged or supported
um cumulative the proposal would cause
impacts on infrastructure and it it also
that response also talks about um
impact um
on eco ecology that biodiversity
landscape heritage and setting and
setting value
and i i wonder whether
uh there's enough substance in there
uh so so where i am is is thinking
do we have the planning reasons
available to us uh reasonably to uh to
refuse the application
uh
my i'm very mindful of the fact having
spent the last two weeks in a public
inquiry
which was about testing the um the
council's reason for refusing
another application
i am highly sensitized to
the need
to get this right but um i
i guess in summary i'm looking for
do we have uh
advice that would support planning
reasons for refusal and in passing i
i do uh
agree with cancer geeks observation
about
the genuine economic contribution that
construction
makes uh we we see this almost by
default in in applications
and i do wonder about the true economic
value
or the distinctive economic uh
contribution of this of this site so
that that's um
that's where i find myself so it's
really
do we have available to us
the uh
reasons planning reasons for refusal and
i i note that the
you know the the observations of
strategic planning policy aren't reliant
on the emergency you know the status of
the the emerging local plan there they
are they stand by themselves
as as worthy comments i think
so really where i i see you coming from
is you're asking the officers
for help to
form some sort of refusal
um but usually that's for us to sort of
produce it to the offices and they'll
amplify it a little um you've mentioned
ecology and
all the other bits as well so i think we
could ask them to assist on that basis
but let's the debates go forward but
would that be am i correct in new york
no that that that's right i i wasn't um
i'm just interested that that's i was
describing where i find myself in
relation
to this application
uh and and in the in the experience
given the experience of
eight days in public inquiry testing
these matters the need for us to be
clear that we have available to us
substantive planning reasons for refusal
but you're right in
in assuming that or understanding that
that's where i'm pointed as it were on
the matter yeah
obviously our recommendation is to
approve the application
if i was to look at the policy position
the policy is correct
that
we don't have a need
for this housing because we have a
five-year financing housing supply
so we haven't eat we've already got need
established at this current time but
need in itself is not something i would
suggest is a reason to refuse it yes
it is not something we would normally do
in planning terms
ultimately the policy team have said
it's not encouraged or supported but
they've not said it's objected to
they've asked us to look at various
aspects of
the policy they've mentioned education
transport and health and we feel we've
sufficiently covered that in your report
and sufficiently covered that in the
consultation responses that we've
received not least from education
highways and health
who have not objected to this proposal
in terms of its merit
it is providing economic benefit from a
construction point of view it's
providing affordable housing from a
housing point of view it is
providing services or occupiers that
will use services in the local local
area
and i would hasten to add that if i look
at the
site that was approved before
it appears to me to be a logical
extension of that existing proposal
that is our argument before you if if
you wish to consider
various other aspects of the principle
of this development um look at the
heritage look at the landscape look at
transport further that is your debate to
continue
does uh councillor carter did you want
to speak or yes yes please
thank you very much um i did wonder
oh
we don't have a consultee of the
disability forum regarding the
application it's not mandatory to have
it but i wouldn't move that we should
have a
if we're mindful if we can't refuse
maybe she might afford to defer until we
have to it
with disability reform and had a a
report of the terrain
um if we are looking to make the
footpath as uh the section
as part of the application well then we
need to know whether or not it's going
to be feasible or whether or not it's
going to be
possible so would it be possible to
defer until we've had further
consultation and
until we've actually had
a
more detailed report of how the footpath
would likely be
well i will um defer to um the officer
in that but the footpath you can't just
pin this footpath on this application
none of the other applications have had
this pinned on them so i don't think we
can do that and that's what john was
trying to explain to you is that it's
not critical well not not critical
that's not the right word it's not
well it's not an essential part of this
planning application it has been offered
so that's a problem um deferring it a
second time i don't think this is
outline anyway
and i personally don't think we should
defer we should either make a decision
one way or the other
and
that is my view am i correct from the
legal side of things yes yes
yes councillor carter
well i would say until we
um as we i have not got that information
and we are up with
hurting v development
where
pedestrians would likely beep
either risk
i'd be minded to move forward diffuser
one
because we do not have the grounds to in
which we can say
we are going to be putting people know
this is going to be
suitable for all to be able to to live
there and for
it to be an accessible and therefore
sustainable development
and i take it that you're offering a
refusal but at the moment before i come
back on that to give some more detail i
think the officer needs to just clarify
something
i would okay
before we go back to the into the
refusal realm let me just go back to the
deferrable realm um
if we were to defer this to see more
information on the footpath link between
elsewhere and woolpit
we would not get any information
available to us that is not that is not
out there it is it is something that
would require
a scheme to be put forward that would
include the highways authority the
county council
um
probably an awful lot of other
landowners
in between and
ultimately you're right it may end up
that that is not a proposal that can go
ahead or it may not go ahead in its
entirety it may only be able to come
together in parts um
so i'm not going to be able to come back
with any information if i was to defer
this on that basis so what you have in
front of you is
is all we've got
if we were to refuse it
on the grounds that the application
fails to provide a footpath link
to
or contribution towards that footpath
link we don't have any details about
that football link
a link that is a gesture
only from the applicant that is
unsupported by any policy
that is unsupported by any evidence
and i don't i guess i don't even know
that of the
possibility of of that coming forward as
a footpath in terms of its physicality i
know there's hills there because i've
been up and down the one to between
amazon and the roundabout many times
um
it is possibly not going to meet all the
standards you know these these are all
of the unknowns and i'm refusing
on that basis that
i'm finding it's very difficult to
express this in the right words
like i said at the very beginning my
comfort from a defendable position for
this council would be not to have that
on here in the first place as a as a
requirement to be secured because i
actually do think it's unnecessary and
unreasonable but if you are considering
that is essential for this application
despite
no other application in elswell having
contributed towards this footpath or
having any similar requirement
we would be in an
extraordinarily poor position to defend
an appeal and would be extraordinarily
subject to such costs
upon the applicant and i would
urge deeply that we do not go down that
road and if we do i would be mindful to
ask for this to go through referrals on
that basis
[Music]
and i must admit when we did have our
little conversation earlier on um
we obviously had that debate and i said
well we've got an offer of a
contribution and i don't think we should
refuse when we're offered something
but if you're trying to make it a
condition of it then we're on we're on
uh wobbly ground let's say yeah did you
want to come back councillor carter
yes i did have a
i do not put we have not got the terrain
information available how suitable it is
for development in this area for access
to the rest of it is it possible to have
a site visit
to uh
well just at the moment we've got a
proposal for a refusal in answer to your
question about a site visit you wouldn't
be looking you'd be looking at the site
and it is the site that is
before us today all the other
i'm afraid whilst you can look at them
is not
relevant to the decision today
it's very difficult to sort of get over
that hurdle and i appreciate what you're
trying to do but bear in mind we have
got others waiting uh councillor
matheson and councillor casten um you
know bear in mind
what you've proposed and what the
officer is advising we need to get this
clear before we move on thank you
i'm trying to work out a better way of
putting this that might be more helpful
um
in the end the application is exactly
what it is before us it's for 65
dwellings
on this site
we don't have a footpath proposal it is
not part of the application
we have a contribution towards the
possibility of one in the future
that is the only thing i've got
and so even if we went on site to look
at the route of a theoretical path
that we have an indicative plan for
perhaps that may not be the root or the
detail or the
anything that we know of uh that would
come forward if and when and i will put
the word if in there a a footpath scheme
comes forward
if you feel this is this scheme 65
dwellings is
hinging on the footpath provision
that is a potential way forward as a
refusal
but i would say would be an exceedingly
weak position to take
as a council
given the lack of policy support for
that footpath provision and the no
evidence whatsoever to say that it would
mitigate the burden of this particular
development
my suggestion
and i the first time i've ever done this
my suggestion would be perhaps the
debate should set that aside for the
temporarily look at any other issues
of the application and if necessary come
back to that but
just as
most my personal suggestion
with that in mind there's two possible
solutions that council carter you and i
have is either for the moment you can
withdraw that proposal or you can look
for a seconder um and there are other
people who've put their hands up who
wish to speak but that's entirely up to
you so until we do that we can't move
forward
being can i read withdrawal until we had
other people speaking and of course you
can come back to us
as the debate moves forward is that in
order
thank you very much right so i had
um
now then who went first was councillor
caston and no i'm sorry john you're down
the line
sorry i think cancer was in front of me
was it all right then go for it i've
i've got them down in the list but
anyway councillor matheson go for it
right very grateful for that um yeah the
there's several things about this i
think
you know i i have a huge frustration
that the you know all right
you know we're trying to to sit here and
and deliberate on that application but
on the other hand and you know in the
real world and as counsellors um you
know we we take a much broader view of
things we we look at them in in a
strategic planning way as
council norris has just pointed to there
earlier
and um
you know
with that you know
with that sort of hat on of
of looking at the the broadly what's
happening with with the various policies
now we're trying to to to produce
strategic planning
working with the county council on
highways and schools working with the
neighborhood plan groups and and indeed
you know other console teams to try and
actually do the overall best thing
and that
you know that
pulls in a different direction to to
decide what's in front of you merits of
the case that's difficult
now what um
what i wanted to point to in particular
was a
slightly different matter right
which is the the problem of the mismatch
of the school provision at the planned
future provision of schools where
there's a site being offered in wool pit
and the fact that the the larger
majority of extra
children are going to arise in elmsworld
and
reading reading all the other papers for
today i happen to see the county council
on page 182
talking about the adverse harm
in of social and environmental
conditions if children had to be bussed
to
another school other than the one in the
village of in this case lacks field
and it seemed to me that
you know that is a fair point
they think there is there is in social
and environmental harm
in in doing what effectively we we're
being
are asked to do
in elmswell and woolpit here so that is
that is a new and different point to the
one about the path
which of course what i'm saying about
strategically looking at the whole
picture
really for 20
20 more than 20 years
wherever peter's gone uh he's left he's
the
the we've wanted to
uh you know we wanted to see these two
villages these twin villages with their
their interchangeable services the
officers said um join together more
sustainably for 20 odd years and and
indeed some of the land was bought by
the the county councillor
um
12 or 15 years ago
councillor matthews just a minute just
before you finish
what we need to be careful of is not
bringing in the next application into
this application which is is very
difficult not to do and i appreciate it
and i appreciate we've also got wall pit
who are going to possibly be providing
the school for these children and i
appreciate that but we've got to be very
careful this is a very difficult line to
walk and i appreciate you've looked at
everything so if you'd like to finish it
well i'm not i'm not i'm not saying that
that lacks field holds any any
precedence or anything what i'm saying
is that i recognize and as it happens
the county recognized
in another place that there is harm in
of environmental and social conditions
which are two of the three um
legs of sustainability
thank you nathan i've lost the plot as
to who wanted to speak next councillor
caston thank you
yeah
if um if we're talking about hinges
i'm i am
i'm hinged on the um
there's some school place situation it's
um
in
national policy is it's important that
sufficient choice of school places is
available to meet the needs of existing
and new communities
so
on a personal level i feel that there's
not enough school places and this is a
um
this is an issue
but if i was going to um stand in front
of
somebody and argue that policy
to refuse this plan application i think
i'd find it very difficult to convince
them that that's a solid argument for
refusing so i'm stuck now with this
hinge
um
and the and the exact weight that that
carries because there is a um school
available
it's not a very good option but there is
a school available the um
i just i just wondered if
as this is debate
um i'll put that to the members that um
you know i'm i could i'm not i'm not
sure of exactly where i stand here this
is
the the
sort of wrestling with it no well that's
what debate is about is to listen to all
the points but i mean one of the things
that that housing
produces obviously is more children but
not necessarily at the time that they
need to go to school so those at the
school move on and i cannot imagine how
the county calculates children coming
and going and moving and so on but but a
housing estate doesn't automatically
give you so they have statistics i'm
sure to work it out
and not everybody in the catchment area
can have a school built in their area
it's very very difficult one to toy with
and i'm getting whispers down my ear so
i'm with you
struggling with it and if you can help
us you were about to say something
um
i think elmsweil
i'm trying to be cool
some schools haven't been surveyed in
terms of their size um but i think
elmsworth has so that's we shouldn't go
down that road um
ultimately
just to help you with who would i stand
in front of to argue this point
if i was standing in front of a planning
inspector and i want to say i'm refusing
this because i don't think there's
enough
spaces for for children
and i don't have anyone from the
education authority backing me up
who are charged with providing education
for children and development spaces
i wouldn't be in a very good position to
argue it at all and i don't have
education
saying that i have education that have
found a workable solution which they use
and apply across the county
at various stages as they transfer from
making small schools bigger or creating
new schools as they fix
the gaps as they go around
councillor humphreys did i see your hand
up manchester thank you yeah i'm
swinging on that hinge door actually and
my swing was with the education because
it clear states and the letters from the
separate council there aren't enough
places
right now and certainly won't be in the
future to meet this requirement but i
understand that
one development happens places are found
schools are expanded money is available
so
i understand that and i've seen it in
stone market where we've had an influx
of development where there weren't
enough school places or doctors places
but you know what in time they came
because they can't build without the
requirement
and therefore you have to have
requirement well that's development and
and this is catch-22 situation and it
makes it extremely difficult for us but
again it's not i don't think a reason
for
um
turning this down john i'll come back
um there was one
in my in my knowledge um we're dealing
with the county on this particular issue
uh it was melis i believe where we had
one situation that the county did
actually object on the basis of school
place and that was because the school
had run out of room ultimately the
schools beyond
that range which were seen to be within
reasonable transport range had also got
no capacity or unable to be expanded to
have that capacity and it was only at
that point that crunch point that they
said do you know what this is not
sustainable on that basis
the problem here is we're not at that
point yet and it's it is depressing to
say that because it's not
it's not a an ideal world in that
context i'm getting quoted for saying
that it is not ideal but i'm faced with
that's the system i've got to work with
thank you and that is a good response um
and coming on to that and uh councillor
mansell explained the fact that buses
may be provided to take children to
school uh and would you put your
four-year-old on a burst well i did
and many parents do but that's a choice
thing and it is a choice thing and it's
subjective so
that's the answer to that as to whether
you would or whether you wouldn't um but
we've got to come down to what this is
and this is an application for
development in elmswell that that's what
it is and why is it before us again well
it's before us again because actually in
the last debate we had the main concern
was highways not schools
not catchment areas highways and we
wanted more information to come back
about mitigation for the highways issues
that's why we're here so we're going
down a few rabbit holes here the
footpath one i wish it wasn't here it's
a big red herring and it's got nothing
to do with development let's face it so
let's let's cut that right down the
middle and say what it is it's nothing
to do with development and my question
is have the questions been answered
about the highways issues that are
identified by this committee in the
previous time it came towards us and i
think they have to be honest with you um
but what's going against some of this is
the fact that this area isn't within the
emerging joint local plan there's an
identified place for development within
elmswell and to me
that that's significant
so it's got no reason for being there it
to me though it's a natural place to put
it but that's not the point it's a
personal opinion um it's not in the
joint emerging plan there is no local
neighborhood plan at the moment and
therefore
i'd like to ask on the legal side and
the planning side how that bears in this
decision the fact that it's not in our
emerging joint local plan is an
identified area for development and
therefore what weight has that got if we
move towards
not approving this application i'm not
i'm not even aware at the moment i'm
swinging on the fence so like an answer
to that please before i go on
sorry
just need to rehearse that quickly
um
ultimately
that's the point of this debate um your
discretion
is how much weight you wish to apply to
your local plan
your local plan does not have this site
within
any settlement boundary
um the fact that the local plan
in part does not comply with the nppf
but what it doesn't in the policies are
out of date but that's not to say they
have no weight but how much weight you
applied to them is your discretion
equally the joint
draft local plan does not have this
site allocated within the
within itself and ultimately i would
advise you that in my opinion that has
little weight but that's not to say it
doesn't have no weight and again if you
wish to consider that in this particular
case for this particular site that
you're giving that more weight as a
direction of travel
and i use that phrase because we have
used that before
then that is your discretion to take
that forward if you wish
thank you
which doesn't make it any easier
because actually at times and i'm a key
example of this where i'll use the
emerging joint local plan
that has little weight as some weight
and i use that to my advantage and the
advantage of some of the approvals that
we put through
so conversely i should do the same when
there's debate that might move the other
way and i think that's fair so so my
point is this um i think there is enough
mitigation in the transport plan
by highways
that the original questions that we
asked have been answered
whether you think they're satisfactory
or not i think that's to determine
between ourselves
when it comes to should we
agree
for this develop to go ahead
then i've got to think about is there a
need
and we've got a five-year land supply
and i understand that as we turn things
down that erodes the five-year land
supply for the future but i think in the
emerging joint local plan there is
enough provision for land
and allocated areas for development that
would equal an argument out personally
for a development of this size which
isn't significant
so is there a need
and this is where i'm on that hinge door
it's actually moving in a direction at
the moment i've got to be honest with
you um
i'm not going to propose anything right
now i i just think
you've got to consider is there a need
for this there's nothing to back up that
need as far as i'm concerned and that's
the problem with it
now did i see councillor norris before
councillor matheson did i see you put
your hand up i couldn't imagine things
don't worry
okay people have been unduly generous to
me this morning i know what that's all
about
um
yeah well i i i think we we have to try
and move to a decision and i i'm i'm
going to propose refusal
and and it's on the but on the basis of
the
um the planning well i think that the
neighborhood plan and joint local plan
um with each with little weight both
are against this um as it as expressed
by the planning policy who do not
support it
um together with the points i made about
the um the social environmental
um harm caused by having such a big
mismatch between the location of the
children and the location of the school
well i had councillor humphreys put his
hand up and then councillor carter and
then councillor norris yeah
mom chair thank you uh well
i disagree with the education piece
because of the the statement i made
before and i don't think it's got any
weight actually although it morally is
you know you think that's not right but
actually the education will come so
part of the proposal i disagree with
that element of the proposal and and i
might touch and admit john about maybe
removing that
um
however it's the need and want and um
and i think the the local councillors
the ward members and the parish council
they know their town better than any of
us we've not identified it as
mid-separate district council as an area
for development
therefore i believe there's no need i
also believe there's a adequate
five-year land supply and i believe
there's an adequate provision with the
local emerging local plan that will
provide that for the future um
so everything aside everything that's
been discussed as long as that was taken
out of that proposal
the education piece then i would second
the proposal
did you hear that
because i don't think it's got weight
well i'm i'm i yeah i'm anxious i'm
anxious about um what mr payman g's
gonna have to say about the lack of need
um being being reasonably refused i
entirely agree um we've got
several thousand
planning permissions um and now
outstanding already um but does it stand
up on its own and i you know i think to
me the answer's not not really i mean
the the
what about the the planning policy
objection that isn't the same thing as
need
um i'm trying to rapidly get my head
around the conversation and how i can
phrase a refusal to help members in this
context um
and i'm trying to pull out a couple of
things from previous committees that are
on a similar line but in
um
i'm going to need
the problem with the policy comments is
they don't actually say why it should be
confused
they they just provide that it should be
encouraged and that's not the same thing
and i'm so i don't have a policy
position from them to why i should
refuse it
i just have a speculation towards the
policy of the future
um um
i am mindful of an application
unfortunately my colleague isn't here
um
where
we had an application was it this
committee in often and it was the
unallocated site
and i do remember there must be this
committee because i do remember
councillor carter's comments on it so
and
the phrase that that refusal if i can
find it was about
the
future direction of
proper planning for that development and
while this is on a lot greater scale
it's a similar argument i suspect you're
you're looking at i've got an answer
[Music]
if i may um so mppf and it's para 48
which talks about determining so local
planning authorities may give way to
relevant policies and emerging plans
according to stage preparation etc well
surely the weight is the fact that it's
not part of our emerging plan this is
not an area that's been identified for
development so therefore surely
if it's not there that must have weight
to support the reason for it not being
there
can we just take a breather for a moment
do we want to just stop the can we just
stop the recording for the moment just
have a few minutes i'll come back
right if we can reconvene sorry about
the delay there um john has some words
of wisdom for us
are you all right councillor carter
all right do take your time
okay so um
well thank you for the time i'm just
trying to put some words together that
i'm hoping captures
what has been discussed and
obviously members please help me with
this as we go along as it's your reason
for refusal um but i i'll put it this
way and see if this
finds um
agreement with you
so i've proposed a reason for refusal
could read to as follows
the application would result in the
expansion of elms well to the west and
place a burden on the infrastructure of
the village to cope
the site is unallocated in the
local plan 1998 core strategy and focus
review
and is not proposed i should say
apologies
not proposed to be
uh allocated in the joint uh draft local
plan
sorry let me apologize i'm going to
start again the site is unallocated in
the joint location the site is
unallocated in the local plan 1998 core
strategy focus review
and
i need to train
sorry one moment this is
right thank you
i'll start from the top
the application would result in the
expansion of elswell to the west and
place a burden on the infrastructure of
the village to cope the site is an
unallocated site in the local in the
local plan 1998 a core strategy and
focus review and is not proposed to be
allocated in the draft joint local plan
as an allocated site for sustainable
housing demonstrated to be supported by
services
while the emerging
joint local plan does allocate
development within elmsworld the
infrastructure development plan makes
account of this and provision is made
for the expansion of facilities and
services to cope with development on
allocated sites this site is unallocated
and as such outside of the
infrastructure development plan such
that there may be no capacity within
existing services including school
provision to accommodate the increased
population that is expected with this
application
in conclusion the emerging local plan is
given reasonable weight alongside policy
the current policy position for proper
planned development as directed by the
nppf and the merits and benefits of the
proposal are not considered to outweigh
the risk to sustainability of future
development of this settlement
can i just say um
listening to that and listening to the
debate we did have i think it was
councillor ghoul mentioned heritage
for for something didn't you yeah i did
because that that is mentioned in the um
in the strategic housing in the policy
things under the impacts i think
uh i just wonder if we if
members want it we haven't quite
accepted this but whether it's of any
relevance or would it weaken the
the thing or is i don't know john you're
the proposer and yeah the the um
yeah i mean i i think john john's done a
you know a good good job for us there um
i i think there's a couple of points i i
was before we we had the intermission i
was going to point to the um the thought
that um planning policy
will have a set of reasons why they
didn't allocate the site which you could
look up if you want to but i mean i
think you
you embrace them in a broad way anyway
and um
i think it would be
only fair to to mention the the also
emerging neighborhood plan um which
again doesn't propose to allocate it
either
um but um i thought with those minor
points i'm i'm i think it's yes
councillor gould
i think so too i think that that
john has actually um
phrased what my thoughts were i think
i've kept looking at the national
planning framework and we have a
under
sustainable development it talks about
fostering a well-designed and safe built
environment with accessible services
which have been listening to the
comments about this proposal and i just
don't feel there's been very strong
arguments
that have supported that claim
before we go on further did we have a
second because we should have a seconder
to this you did second it and and
councillor humphreys are you happy with
what's been worded already
and
mojo yeah i know like congratulate john
really on coming up with that it's a
short time under pressure so well done
it captures i think everything we spoke
about um however the heritage bit has
not been answered so i don't know if you
want to add that or not
um
no i thank you i
i i thought uh
mr peyton g's um
summary there of reasons is uh was
exactly felt exactly right and
uh i mean the
i was quoting from the policy position
on page 143
which includes heritage
easy in a sense it's it's implied in
what mr paytman g
has said
i'm i'm uncertain and easy about
including if you like a second emerging
plan in it you know it might look like
carelessness to have a second one in
there but but the um
uh i think give me interrupting do you
mean the lo the neighborhood yes yes so
you're right
i have to add that
so i'm uneasy about adding that in
because i think it it it dilutes um
mr pate mcgee's uh wording thank you
i support the recommendation for um
as stated however i agree with the local
neighbourhood plan because actually it's
down to the district council to find and
allocate land so i think that's that's
captured within the local emerging local
plan so i don't think the neighborhood
plan is required to be honest with you
it's a minor point
can i have counselor norris first it
it's it's our game yes thank you um just
to say that i support the recommendation
for refusal i don't think we have had
all the answers from highways actually i
think there's a lot of supposition in
the response on page 13 in the table of
papers and i would suggest that the
reason that strategic planning policy
do not support
this
application uh is their statement that
cumulatively the proposal would cause
impacts on infrastructure without going
on too long i think that's quite evident
that there are issues regarding
junctions which will be
according to highways
predictions will be over capacity
they put forward what i regard to be
opinion rather than fact in the drivers
are going to find alternative routes
etc up so therefore i can't support the
the original recommendation for approval
and i do support the recommendation for
refusal thank you thank you for that
well i think if we're clear on what
we've got before us i think we've had a
jolly good debate and timeouts on this
one um
i i don't know i think we've heard from
john was quite clear on it and other
proposer and second are happy with that
and on that basis i think we can
go to a vote the only sad thing that
bothers me a bit is
you know the highways have tried to come
back to us
i know the area extremely well
i did write here
something that just sort of suggests a
bit of incredulity
that they would look up a train time to
decide when they were going to go in
their car
so
i think that one is a little bit
thin on the ground for that um that said
this is a really difficult application
and the officers work extremely hard to
try to come to a conclusion on this and
that is what we do here is a debate and
we swing one way or the other and that
to me demonstrates that we do not have a
fixed view before we get here we debate
we decide and we vote so on that basis
all those in favor of the refusal the
recommendation per given please vote
yes thank you
so we are unanimous thank you very much
indeed and
it was a very difficult case thank you
can we keep going please because um we
need to crack on
madam chairman um
you don't need me while you're
presenting absolutely that's fine thank
you very much for that ian thank you
we're just going to have literally a
three minute break just for um
a personal
requirement
right thank you very much for your
patience and thank you very much indeed
we move on page 179
and jack wilkins is going to present the
case for us thank you
good afternoon members and members of
the public i'm jack wilkinson i'm
principal planning officer
for babera mid-suffolk
your next item is item 7c
page 179 onwards
it's an outline application
with all matters reserved except access
for the erection of 49 dwellings
with associated operations
uh including vehicular pedestrian
access
provision of a school car park open
space infrastructure and landscaping
so probably before i move on um it's
worthwhile noting that your officers
were in receipt um and which is tabled
as a late paper
um of a letter from the parish council
that requested the secretary of state to
call in this item
um your officers have consulted uh legal
colleagues and we are sound procedurally
within which to proceed this application
is yet to be determined as you well know
um so in terms of procedural propriety
it's it's it's good for us to proceed
so as mentioned we are in lax field
towards the north east of the district
as shown by the defined red line
[Applause]
so as i'll just indicate we have the
site towards the southwestern corner
the
thicker
brown line which
is clear on the screen shows the
existing settlement boundary of what is
a primary village
the site kind of tucks towards the
southwestern edge in this small
agricultural enclave which adjoins the
built settlements
in terms of the emerging joint local
plan um
the extension to the settlement is shown
here in pink so it does overlap slightly
but you will apply appropriate weight as
required
in terms of the constraints the site is
largely unconstrained
towards the left here
which hopefully you can just about see
is a
definitive public right-of-way
we also have um mill road which is a
spur off of the main kind of
trunk road through
lax field
the main high street of lax field is is
here as shown as you can see the densely
built form we have a great list of
building opposite the site here
and most notably is the primary school
which is just kind of highlighted where
the red market is
so into the next slide is an aerial view
the site is principally agricultural in
nature
um and in terms of the topography of the
landscape it's relatively flat it does
tend to slope
off
southwest into the lower kind of datum
point area of the site
but it does sit relatively well amongst
the build settlement which i'll discuss
in a moment
in terms of the services and facilities
whilst this is a primary village there
are good services
and your officers have been through that
assessment in terms of the accessibility
to
and indeed from and whether lax field is
fit for purpose to serve a scheme of
this nature and extent
so you do have the king's head you have
the cricket club
you have the royal oak
there's a co-op in the center
recreation ground
a pre-school
which is just off here and indeed the
primary school which i've spoken about
already so there is quite a good range
now as mentioned this is an outline
application so we're looking at a the
principle of development and b the
access
those are the two components that are up
for debate today everything else is
reserved but nonetheless this indicative
layout does give you quite a good idea
of what could be built out
and it's worthwhile mentioning that this
would be fixed through section 106 which
i will discuss later on and indeed
conditions
now
in terms of the key components
which hopefully you can just about make
out
we have um
an area here which is
isolated
for 17 car parking spaces and an
additional car parking space area here
which can also be used by the school
this is captured
by your offices in the section 106 as 34
spaces now
if for instance we were to recommend or
you were to go with the recommendation
of approval
this would come through
at a later date with the reserve matters
with this as a minimum
threshold so it would be 34 spaces
secured
there's also an opportunity here to
create a link a pedestrian level
from mill road into site and vice versa
that way the site is relatively fluid
from the west where the public right of
way is
through the site
and off into the main settlement you've
also got abundant public open space
and towards the lower extremity of the
site
local lead flood authority compliant
attenuation these are the kind of facts
and figures that we can take from the
scheme it's a 4.29 hectare site
and the density is well within
the confines of what would be policy
compliant
we've also managed to secure 35
affordable housing that is ndss
compliant
that is a national standard
of
compliant affordable housing
so these facts and figures again will be
captured within the 106 which we can
refer to later
[Applause]
just taking you on to the frontage of
the site
this is
the
far eastern corner you may wish to
follow the arrow which is in the bottom
left here and obviously the site map
which you'll follow as i go around site
with the photos
you'll see conveniently i park my car
here opposite the site which is
currently used as a pupil drop off
remember the school is on the right hand
side
this is really close to the school
this is the approximate position of
the proposed entrance the existing site
frontage
and a view facing
south
now in terms of the access again this is
a detailed matter
that we are here to discuss today
i've just chosen to overlay some
highlights on this just so it's clearer
but you can see
the primary school here
along with residential units towards the
east that are within the defined
settlement boundary and indeed those
opposite the listed building is just
slightly off shot
the access arrangement as shown in green
clearly defined
in both directions
the visibility is set at 90 meters and
this is beyond compliant
and your highways engineers from the
county council have
written to us and confirmed that so just
to go back the visibility
is as shown
so it's readily achievable
now along the frontage would be a
pedestrian footpath i've chosen to
highlight that in yellow just to make it
expressly clear
where the frontage would be so as
existing if you can remember we had a
frontage here that was mainly of
hedgerow
what's proposed
is a clear pedestrian footpath that
would serve not only the site but also
the southwestern extent of the village
there's a little blue arrow here which
i'll zoom in on in a moment that
outlines the crossing point so
effectively if you are you know staff
pupils parents
and you've opted to park
as proposed in sight you're going to
need to access safely and sufficiently
it's a 30 mile an hour stretch along
this point
and there is a crossing point proposed
with abrasive material
no pelican or toucan crossing or
anything like that but
there are clear measures that are shown
and agreed with county council
[Applause]
so just to discuss a little bit further
again follow me on the map
we have
a footpath link to mill road
which is a readily deliverable aspect
and again it's an improvement that you
know we would welcome
that can be integrated as any future
reserve matters application would and we
would secure that through planning
condition
this is the existing site facing east
the public right of way that i've
already mentioned
located west
so the site would provide quite a good
link subject to final design
so site photos
much of the site is quite well bound
actually by
hedgerows this is a view towards the
north of existing residential units
as you'll see the site is
agricultural land at present
this is a view facing north with the
school just on the right hand side
residential dwellings opposite
this is quite a central point
and i will choose to flick through these
because we can rever refer back to them
if you so wish
[Applause]
and that just gives you an idea of the
existing
hedgerow towards the front
and indeed the existing highways
arrangement you'll note there's no
footpath this scheme would provide that
footpath
the school opposite
and
my car which was just parked during my
visit opposite the site
in the
lay-by
so final summary
this is a scheme for 449 units it's
probably worthwhile noting as well that
the scheme actually came in for a much
higher number
but the
applicant has responded well to initial
comments and has come in a much lower
number hence re-consultation with key
consultees
affordable housing at 35
which is of a good quality ndss
compliance standard we now require that
pretty much across the board
and the benefits that accrue
so your recommendation is for approval
from officers subject to the section
106.
thank you
thank you very much that was very clear
questions yes councillor carter and then
councillor matheson then councillor
warboys and then councillor norris will
come down in that row thank you
uh firstly we just want to say um thank
you for the presentation it's very
very informative very well diamonds
quite an attractive presentation
i just wanted a query regarding the
parking i don't fall over this always a
good idea right
with school parking is that
for use for the staff or is it for
um
for
parking for students
and
would there be any provision for
electric charging points
thank you for your question and kind
words um
this would be
additional car park drop off so
principally it would be by
parents bearing and mine's a primary
school it's unlikely to be used by
pupils
there would be scope to introduce say ev
charging points uh detailed matters um
but certainly the principle of securing
35 spaces whether it's one car park or
two as shown on the indicative layout
that that would be that would be secured
so i'll leave that with you
you want to come back yes please
wondering um
by the development how much bigger is
the
school going to get for the need for the
extra if there's going to be
more places available for extra students
for allow for extra drop off
indeed and again i think the important
part here is that
the school
as per the comments of the county
council would no doubt in the future be
expanded upon
this would very much facilitate and
enable
future growth of that school should the
county council wish to deliver that
it does enable and it does assist i
would say proportionately
for lax field so it is a healthy
response and certainly a benefit that
we've taken positively
thank you for that councillor matheson's
next yeah did you get any response from
the environmental management officer as
discussed a day or two ago
i think what you're referring to
is
matters which refer to detailed outline
so you'd have
details that would come through in terms
of sustainability
and a condition to that effect we
haven't consulted the sustainability
officer because there's no duty upon us
to do so
this is an outline application
if we were looking at this at reserve
matters
we could do that i'll leave it with you
to decide as to whether you wish to
consider a sustainability condition
apologise for this coming in but um just
to clarify um we don't normally consult
our colleagues in environmental level on
this basis they look at the applications
that come in and they choose to comment
when they wish
we don't have comments from them on that
basis for this application
council of war boys thank you
yeah thank you i just want to clarify
the crossing point that's just indicated
by a drop curve there's no flashing
lights or signage or
there's no flashing lights no token no
pelican
no abrasive it would simply be at the
pavement i think you've got to remember
this is a 30 mile an hour stretch
which would be paved either side
as required by the detail
and it would be
dropped kerb sloping in with abrasive
kind of um
foot measures that would enable you to
cross this would be captured under the
highways remit
you know
we're falling outside of the red line
here but
there wouldn't be any you know toucan or
lights or anything like that
thank you councillor norris
questions still
thank you yes uh
on page 185
3.5 relates to
policy cs2
development in the countryside
finishes up by saying the proposal does
not constitute speak up please sorry can
you speak up even i can't yeah okay
i'll start again then
all right uh page 185 3 paragraph 3.5
policy cs2 relates to developing in the
countryside
and that paragraph
finishes up by saying the proposal does
not constitute any of the
category of housing types listed in
policy cs2 the site is not a rural
exception site there is no policy
support for the proposal to be found at
policy cs2 there are also items in the
following paragraphs which says its
proposal to policy eight seven
and over the page the proposal finds no
support paragraph 79 of the mppf i'm
tempted to ask why is this
application before us then committee
thank you
thank you thank you for your question
firstly this item is is a committee
because it's a scheme for in excess of
15 units by our delegated power we have
to go by that we have to present it to
you
i think in terms of the content within
the officer report
i do i do know those those comments
if you're assessing this scheme against
policy cs2 there is technical conflict
however we are where we are with policy
in the age of it
that being said
i have discussed this in the planning
balance and there are two appeal cases
that i've cited along with paragraph 59
of the mppf which is
clear in what government have said that
we are required to boost homes
i think
the final element of that planning
balance
is to do with
the winger worth case and it states that
whilst you may have a land supply it's
not a ceiling height
therefore we still have an onus on us to
deliver homes in the right locations and
that is what the planning balance
outlines
hopefully that provides an idea of the
reasoning behind why it was mentioned
and then how it's been concluded
thank you anyone else any questions i
think councillor humphreys thank you
chair thank you it's just referenced the
open space management scheme so can you
confirm that this won't adversely affect
those in affordable rented accommodation
so in terms of the 106 it is recommended
that
there would be a management company in
place however this is also termed within
the report
if i can just find the paragraph
it would be paragraph 17.1 page 193
or some other arrangement so that would
enable us as the authority to consider
some other arrangement whether that be
with a parish or whoever else
thank you any further questions was it
council carter did you want to come back
on a question again
leave it for debate yeah okay then right
thank you very much indeed so thank you
for that
we now have so in this the parish
council chair if you'd like to come
forward please thank you
good afternoon good afternoon chair and
members
we strongly believe that this
application should be refused one of the
arguments put forward in the committee
paper presented to you hangs on an
appeal against a planning decision made
by waverly borough council this judgment
includes the key sentence the spatial
strategy acknowledges that it will not
be possible to accommodate the necessary
growth within existing development
boundaries we do not believe this
judgment is relevant to application
under consideration it's a fundamentally
flawed argument the mid-suffolk local
plan as currently adopted does not
acknowledge the need to allow
development beyond existing settlement
boundaries as the waverly borough local
plan does
quite the opposite is true here
to quote the settlement boundary
objectives of the local plan are to
restrict unnecessary encroachment into
the surrounding countryside
to allow for development and changes of
use within existing settlements without
detriment to their character
and settlement boundaries have been
drawn to exclude sites which if
developed would detract from the form
and character of the settlement
save policy sb1 is directly relevant
here new development will take place
within existing
settlements we would like you to
consider carefully also the scale and
the cumulative impact of this
development
this development represents more than 10
percent of the existing village in a
single urban scale development
lacks field has already delivered 64 of
the 65 houses indicated in the joint
local plan preferred options paper
within a very short time scale
a further application for 11 homes is
awaiting a decision
we believe that the cumulative impact of
this proposal in addition to recent
permission for new development would be
substantial and extremely damaging to
the existing community
and the character of the village it
would overwhelm the local infrastructure
services and amenities we have good
facilities but they would be overwhelmed
by yet more development
it should also be borne in mind that
although lacks field is currently
designated as a primary village
its designation in the emerging joint
local plan is as a hinterland village
which means it is far less sustainable
than other settlements in the district
i would refer you to the response from
the senior policy strategy planner which
concludes that the principle of
development is considered unacceptable
the points i've made today are in
addition to the objections we've
previously raised which still stand in
their entirety
a decision to permit this development to
take place would in our view be both
unreasonable and irrational
unreasonable in disregarding views
expressed by the local community the
cumulative impact of growth and
particularly of
an additional development to this scale
and the impact on the well-being of the
existing community
and irrational in some of the reasoning
used to reach such a decision such as
the omission of paragraph 77 of the nppf
paragraph 77 says that planning policies
and decisions should be responsive to
local circumstances and support housing
developments that meet local needs
and to quote the oxford english
dictionary
local means relating or restricted to a
particular area or one's neighborhood
not the wider area
thank you
thank you very much indeed does anybody
have any questions for miss sims
yes councillor caston thank you
um
as the chair of the parish council have
you experienced parking issues
from the due to the primary school
that we believe they could easily be
overcome by other means
we do not need an additional car park
opposite school
do you have any um other means
that you've
that you as for an example
yes there is for example a redundant
swimming pool um
opposite the proposed entrance that
swimming pool building is that facility
is completely unused there would be an
option potentially to extend the school
there and to retain the existing school
park car park the school has a large
site there are other options available
within the existing site
thank you any further
questions thank you would you just press
the button off thank you that's fine
we now have an objector in petit if
you'd like to come forward too please
thank you very much
do start
thank you chair good afternoon
a housing needs assessment produced by
aecom for the neighborhood plan
confirmed that at the time of the last
census there were 910 people living in
lax field
this development would increase the
number by more than 10 percent
the assessment also disclosed that an
overall need of 27 dwellings which
equates to two drillings per year
between 2014
and 2036.
in the feedback from the neighborhood
plan consultation there was no support
for any individual development with more
than up 10 dwellings or for any future
development outside the build-up area
boundary however measured and organic
growth is welcomed
the overriding feeling amongst the
community is that the development of
this scale will totally destroy the
social fabric of the village
the claims for sustainability are a myth
and do not stand up to scrutiny
employment translates as workmen
arriving in ones and twos in cars and
vans from some distance away leaving a
damaging carbon footprint
local employment will not benefit
the travel officer from suffolk county
council says that the existing
sustainable transport infrastructure is
limited for commuting purposes it is in
fact non-existent
there is no public transport for
residents to use to get to medical
facilities or other services
road safety is a major cause of concern
to the residents who witness the reality
of traffic problems in the vicinity of
the school the road is gridlocked at the
beginning of every school day and the
volume and nature of the
is already a severe risk particularly
young children
a concerned parent recently notified the
parish council of a near-miss had
witnessed
the development now proposed would mean
an additional 100 or so vehicles joining
the road network at this location and 11
pupils needing transport to secondary
schools out of the village thereby
exacerbating the problem
further evidence of the unsustainable
nature of this development
the council's own senior policy strategy
planner says that the immediate rural
highways networks around the area are of
poor quality to be able to successfully
and practically accommodate such a major
urban proposal
which would represent a disproportionate
and incongruous development unsuitable
to this rural location
the road network is inadequate
the committee report uses a case to
confirm that development should only be
prevented or refused on highways grounds
if there will be an unacceptable impact
on highway safety and makes reference to
a court case
this mod was taken up by the inspector
in a planning appeal number 16 oblique
3159 207
who confirmed that road safety is not a
matter falling under the ambit of
paragraph 109 of the framework therefore
this paragraph is no relevance in these
circumstances and this development can
be refused on highway grounds
laksfield is a thriving community
and currently a great place to live it's
friendly busy welcoming but united in
its opposition to this development
respectfully i urge you
in the name of good planning and common
sense to refuse the application thank
you
thank you very much do members have any
questions
thank you very much indeed if you'd like
to return to your seat thank you
and
sorry
just getting some now we have um james
platt here who's the consultant for the
application
he isn't going to speak as such but do
you have any questions for the
applicant at all members
does anyone have any questions for him i
know we haven't heard we've seen the
presentation and we see what's before us
no
thank you for attending but it doesn't
seem that we need to
discuss with you
thank you so we now come to julie um
council flatman who's the ward member if
you would please thank you very much
thank you chair members
you have heard the representations from
the parish i can only reiterate the
views of the community the lacksfield
neighborhood plan is out for official
consultation on the saturday the 22nd of
february a lot of hard work has gone
into the plan with allocated sites
we are also working with mid-suffolk on
our community housing housing trust to
produce our own houses that are
available to people at an affordable
rent but don't fall under the trap of
right to buy belonging to the village
for those who need housing and cannot
get on the housing ladder for whatever
reason the village has many small sites
self builds and many local builders to
build them which is more in keeping with
a hinterland village as stated in the
emerging local plan
the plan proposes 65 dwellings
which we will easily deliver and more
besides
we know the need to grow and encourage
young families
we want to be vibrant and sustainable we
need to keep our school and expand it
we have a lovely shop pubs businesses
and clubs all growing and thriving we
know this but we need to be in control
not have the likes of suburbia thrust
upon us with the same houses you can see
all over the country poorly designed and
dare i say in some cases thrown up
why
pass large unwanted developments where
you could have many smaller outstanding
and individual sites which enhance our
small village
it states in the papers under health
that the local practice is framing him
it's in fact stradbroke and thressing
field with a percentage of residents
attending framlingham
stradbroke and threshingfield are
definitely at capacity so any
contributions would be needed
highways
what can i say
if only they came out had a look at
eight to nine o'clock am a possible
hundred cars coming out on a school day
the entrance opposite the other entrance
i don't think so
oh sorry buses down to the buses we have
a bus leaving from lax field at about 7
30 to ipswich mainly for students
to get from stradbroke through lacks
field and then on to framingham through
the villages then on to ipswich college
it returns about 7 p.m
as you would have seen in the press
county council have pulled
or
pulled or are pulling all our buses in
other in our village that go to the
small market towns locally so the car is
the only means for all and those elderly
residents who have now given up their
cars have no means at all
what i wanted to ask was no i'll carry
on with this first
[Applause]
uh
okay um
two if members are minded to pass this
development i strongly suggest that the
developer consults with the perishing
community to come up with a sim with
sympathetic designs appropriate to the
rural setting
and as and down to the school at present
a teacher stands in the road to see the
children across the road
as they come off the school coach
the primaries
the primary children come off the second
secondary school children get on
i really do think a safety crossing of
some sort should be considered
if the
development goes ahead
um down towards the village for the
children to cross over safely or at the
other entrance that came up on slide 17
because
it is so dangerous there
um
i did want to ask some other things as
well um
uh slide 17
i'd like to see oh what is the grade of
the land
you saw its agricultural land what is
the grade please
the grade on the land the agriculture
[Applause]
foreign
at the moment it is
used for agriculture
okay um can we have slide 17 up please
[Music]
okay so at the moment where that arrow
is the school coach stops there and it
is absolutely gridlocked for quite a
long while so i don't know how it's
going to work but if it did go ahead i
think you would definitely need to have
a zebra crossing or something
probably
a bit further down i don't know but it
it definitely does need some sort of
safety
process in there
um a zebra crossing at the very least
i don't know it'll be up to members to
debate
um thank you chair
so i think you've given us a lot of
information there and very passionately
too thank you it's it's not easy when
you've sort of listened to debate and
then got it written down one question i
do have of you
um were you aware that part of this site
is extended into the joint local plan
oh yes
so housing would be built on it one
would assume
slightly not
some of it
yeah exactly but it is part in part of
it
and the other thing is you mentioned
that you've got capacity for 65 houses
and this is for 49. so if you had 65
would you still have oh gosh the same
number of vehicles is what i'm trying to
say you'd have oh no no i went on 49.
if you if you look at cars going in and
out of there so you've got cars no no no
you said your local plan has capacity to
develop 65 houses no that's the area
sorry the local plan the emerging local
plan not your neighbor no not our
neighbors so you haven't allocated any
sites
oh yes we have for how many
how many
yeah but that's the numbers i'm curious
about oh there's a report on it it's in
the late papers
right okay okay i'll look at them yeah
but um i'm just thinking yeah if you put
it in there yeah okay it's not too bad
it's okay okay we've got 26 i think
coming forward at the moment no it's not
at the moment it's what's
unfortunately neighborhood plans have to
plan for the future not what's already
gone in and i think that's different
it doesn't matter people are still
confused about how the neighborhood i
think it's important
okay they will be coming forward thank
you and did you want to say something
yes if i may madam chair thank you i
think it's worthwhile having listened to
all the comments um that have come in
it's probably just worthwhile just to
recap on a couple of elements before you
do enter into debate
the
case which we've cited
from waverly
is based also on a
in principle countryside development
policy now word for word on the evidence
before me the policy in relevance to
waverly is up to date for the purposes
of demonstrating that the council is a
five-year housing land supply in that
respect
that is based on an up-to-date policy
our policy is slightly out of date
therefore it weakens our position
further
that basis means that it is entirely
relevant
and along with that paragraph 59 which
i've already mentioned of the nppf
what i'd also like to just
add to as well so that members are
entirely transparent and clear before
they enter into debate
is that you have
a policy comment which was based on 65
dwellings
which is now redundant
because the applicant has amended the
scheme to 49 much less
and we have a response from
the strategic planning policy and
infrastructure team
on page 269 to 270
that is i would say falling on the side
of positive along with the
infrastructure develop delivery plan
position
so
i just want to make those points
clear for members to consider before
they enter into debate
there's one final aspect as well
this outline application is recommended
with a 24 limit timer time limit for a
24 month time limit
this isn't 36 months not three years
it's 24 months
so i think that shows a little bit of
intent from the applicant thank you
actually that clarifies the 65 number
that i was querying about i think that's
very helpful to plead that point right
um where are we now
thank you for that
any questions for councillor flatman if
you would please
counselor matheson please yeah was there
any um pre-application engagement
between the applicant and the and the
village neighbourhood plan team
right okay thank you
anyone else questions no i think
councillor flatman gave us a good um
a lot of information there thank you
very much thank you for that
so we go into the debate now then oh yes
we're into the debate now please
councillor humphrey
thank you um
yeah
i see lots of villages uh coming forward
for development i feel really sorry for
people living those villages but it's
the world we live in because there's
been an identified need for more
affordable housing and more development
and that's government-led and there's a
real need anyway in suffolk for that
affordable housing as outlined
in
page 204 which comes from
the
housing enabling officer it talks about
690 applicants registered affordable
housing in this district well without
affordable housing there'll be more
people next time more people again so
there's definitely a need for it they
also talk about the need for um
two-bedroom houses one bedroom bungalows
that sort of thing which is important as
well which this actual development
brings
i'll come to the development a couple of
ways
safety we talk about the congestion
along the road at the moment and i get
it there's a school there
people park along the road everybody
wants to take their children to school
by car because they've got other things
to do like go to work afterwards and
it's reasonable isn't it we live in the
modern world
as much as we like people to walk
so you're always going to have that
problem
this development actually mitigates
against some of that problem by
providing parking provision but well
it's debatable it's my point um it's
provides provision for parking off-road
which is a good thing and for safety
that takes a big box doesn't it it also
allows provision eventually for the
expansion of that school and we talk
about crossing the road because that
still is an issue isn't it and in lots
of schools in lots of places in suffolk
including the stone market and the
teacher or somebody walks out and stops
traffic where it's appropriate that's a
common thing and i think it's
commendable
on this one though we do get a crossing
point and all that's not pelican it's
not a full pedestrian crossing it does
allow excess and it's a 30 mile an hour
zone so it's reasonable to expect that a
parent with a child would look both ways
before crossing at that point and would
allow push chairs and everything else in
wheelchairs access as well so that's a
good thing as well
for the bus parking across the road from
it well the bus can move the bus can
move a few meters down the road the
reason why because there's now more
parking available because we've done
off-site parking so that's a good thing
as well
so safety-wise i think it ticks the
boxes
i've looked at the highway side they're
against it initially holding up
obligation unless certain things came
through and that was the pedestrian
crossing all the other things i've just
mentioned and i think they we tipped the
box on all of those i like the plan as
well if i'm perfectly honest 65 houses
i'd have raised an eyebrow 49 i think
fits nicely if we look at the plan even
this is outline i'll come back to this
point in a moment it sits well
when you think about the landscaping
around it and i know this is outline and
i'll come to that point in a moment
it gives really good
protection as you're driving towards the
town of the impact of that development
as you approach and i think that's a
reasonable and really sensible way of
doing it they plan this really well
i've got to say
personally
i've got one consideration though on the
attenuation pool that would need some
protection for the children that are
going to live on that site because
that's a natural draw for the children
to go to it's open space and it's water
guess what attracts kids so i'd like to
see something in there that protects
those children against that risk as
everything else seems to be risk-based
and seems to tick the boxes
so the layout i'm happy with the road
layout i'm happy with the provision of
the affordable houses and the type of
houses including the two bungalows i'm
happy with and it meets the need of the
district
and i think the smaller bollywood
smaller developments perhaps wouldn't
bring that affordable housing which is
needed in laxfield and elsewhere so this
is why this development's important
safety is taken care of there are
benefits to the school benefits to the
people in the town
however if i was going to move for
approval on this and i am minded to
then i'd like to see a condition added
that for the reserve matter layout to be
in accordance with the indicted plan
because i think that's important because
that is a really good plan and i'd hate
that to change
that's my condition if i was going to go
for approval but i'll wait until the
debate develops that would be a really
good condition to add
as long as as long as the debate goes
that way and people are minded to agree
with me
yeah okay so
i am mindly pro for approval to keep
this short and to stop it coming back to
me and we can debate this all day really
for all the reasons i've raised
i can't see a reason for refusal
therefore i'm minded to approve and
therefore i propose approval of this
with the condition
that
the reserve matter layout is in
accordance with the plan that's laid
before us and the condition that we have
the safety element around the
attenuation pool because that's
extremely important
um i know we're going to electric
charging so i would like a provision on
that because i think that's probably
important especially with the
car parking it's public that's available
that's my position
[Music]
just a quick because i've got electric
charging which i normally highways would
just stick that in but i don't think
they have on this occasion so we do need
to add that um so electric charging
points for the households um general
according to the inductive plant that's
fine um
the caveat i would provide though in
terms of the
attenuation basin
um our colleagues in the county council
are revising their guidance in respect
of attenuation basins
in order and they want to make sure
they get them right early on
so
they are i don't want to the general
accordance i would there is a
possibility the generation basement
could get bigger because that means it
gets shallower and therefore it means
it's less of a risk
um in in context to the issue
but on the other hand reserve matters
can pick up on any landscaping fencing
requirements and so on um so i would
just to clarify that and one last point
i just go back to my officer um the
crossing to the uh to the um
the main road in front of the school
i've got the link to mill
mill road
have we i can't see the crossing
immediately in the recommendations
yes but that's
that the same
that is the one yeah
but in terms of highway conditions
so does that work i'll get to the actual
question
my actual question is the crossing
itself
there is room for us to consider
different schemes above what's actually
been indicated so it could possibly be a
better one a better you know zebra
crossing or
pelican cause and we can actually
explore that further if need be it's not
minimal
fine okay so there is a way potentially
we can explore upgrading it if the
highways authority are open to that
debate
can we put
sorry crossing to consider betterment
well can we put that in or is that
something the possibilities have to be
considered
yes you can indeed
oh sorry
do we
um do we need to have an exit so in an
emergency there's an exit not on here
oh not enough okay okay
and one question i have for council
humphreys while we've sort of rather
whistled through that at the moment
john did say um electric for the
households were you considering electric
for the car park as well and can we do
that gentlemen
yeah madam that was my point um the
household one uh that's debatable and um
because you can plug them into the wall
some of them um but i was more concerned
or
considering more the the public parking
area where we could provide at least one
we change that to delegated authority to
explore electrical charging points
because it might be within the gift of
the school
or a management company so can we leave
that for the officers to explore yeah
absolutely thank you definitely
perfect thank you
right that was rather swift next person
counts counselor wall boys off you go
i may maybe sort of jump in the gun a
bit could about the um
crossing i i did sort of catch the
discussion could make it clear that this
is the relocation of the school car park
so
it will be the main car park for the
school so there'll be quite a lot of
um there will be
a lot of use of that crossing so if
there is further
i think our officer can help us a little
bit further
in addition too
it is exactly that madam chair it is in
addition to
so you have the school as existing
and the existing arrangement however
that now sits
this proposal would provide an addition
to that parking area opposite the site
via a parking route
so you have the 34 spaces whether it's
in a block of 17 and another block of 17
you would have that provision within
this proposal and that would be accessed
by
the crossing point so it's an addition
rather than a replacement for the school
i think i've misread what it says then
page 230
it talks about the um
the size of the school site somewhere
[Applause]
and it's too small so if the school had
to expand it would need to increase the
size of the buildings and this would
only be possible if it
um
140 place school would require a minimum
site of approximately 0.667 hectares
which is more than the existing site it
was because it is considered possible to
expand the school by relocating the
school car park which would then allow
building on the existing school car path
yep
that is a worthwhile point councillor
and i think
what the county council are referring to
there is that in the event of
them choosing to expand that school
this scheme would help enable that
through the parking that would be
available it's within the county
council's gift as to whether they choose
to expand that school and this would
future proof that it would enable it
should they so wish
so at the moment it is thank you for
that clarification yeah and also that's
only taking into account all of the
allocations
good point um sorry councillor cast and
then councillor um matthison thank you
i think i'm
leaning over to um councillor humphreys
point of view on this the um
i do like the design i like the density
i like that there's a footpath delivered
where there wasn't one before
the character of the village it is an
incredibly beautiful village maxfield
and anyone that's been there will know
that but unfortunately it's not a museum
and it needs to move forward and it'd be
very bad for that village not to
move forward um
the um
i wonder if the um i would like to see a
proper crossing on on there i'm i think
as soon as these cars that are parking
beside the road
um
they are moved on road speeds will
increase
as they will but that's that's
that's
that's just my personal view people
speed up when there's less in front of
them um
so i'd like to see the cross in there
also
is it possible that we can design
this area the parking area where a coach
can drive in
forwards and leave forwards
so that we can get the coaches off the
side of the road and take that risk out
of it
would that be possible to
have that in the design
i think in terms of the crossing just to
answer that point first um you have what
is before you and also with the actual
design out proper how it would sit on
the ground the county council would be
heavily involved on that in terms of
the recommendation
i've done a similar scheme in the past
and take quite a bit of experience from
that whereby we actually set out a kind
of a construction and design
specification so we've got a
specification of a suitable car park
obviously we can't guarantee the layout
today because that's not we're here to
determine however we can agree a certain
standard
of car park provision is it fit for
purpose and within that we can certainly
take you know whether it's
good for uh large buses to maneuver and
turn and re-enter and forward-facing
gear that would be something at a later
date but we have secured what we can at
this stage
okay
council matheson thank you yeah i i
think i picked up the world members
point she was saying that the
um
the the bus
delivering the school children stopped
virtually where the crossing point is
made and and um so i absolutely agree
with that that that actually needs
thinking through a little bit better and
the officers seem to be offering us
the opportunity that that could be done
which is good i have to say that at the
bottom of page 182
um planning policy are actually saying
that this the relocation of the car park
in order to expand the village is
essential essential
actually
um
it is to use the phrase of the day of
hinge point
uh seems to me um
but that is proposed so that's that
point is overcome i'm just saying it's
it's required
um
for the
for the application to be
satisfactory so i think that's
that one's watching
the um i mean i i agree with cancer
others that there are there are not
strong
arguments for refusal here um
i think it's unfair to say the villages
is um you know got a look that has been
in the 21st century and the rest of it
if the the list in the late papers page
22 of the number of applications that
have already been approved totally in 26
uh in this calendar year
that i'm sorry 2019 calendar year um
shows that they are um that they are
modernizing etc as discussed
so i think that's a little bit unkind
and the other the other point that i
would be looking for
is um
the the
sustainable sustainability and
efficiency
um condition as
the one we put on on the
long farm for example
um at the outline stage
um i i think we are often doing that and
i've heard what the um officers said
about
them not being a
consultant at the outline stage but
that's something we can discuss
anyone else wish to speak do we have it
did we have a second we haven't got a
second we haven't just seconded does
anybody want to second it
um counselor casting yes i'm happy to
second thank you thank you
um so if
does anyone else wish to speak
well i just asked if if if the proposal
and second would it would accept the
sustainability and efficiency
planned to be
agreed
prior to starting whatever it says in
the other one
so does the proposer and the secondary
what exactly did you want um the the
well i i
noting also that the the land actually
slopes south westwards
um
the the
to ask the applicant to draw up
a plan to achieve good sustainability
and efficiency in in carrying through
the development is what we're asking in
other cases and i
think about a scheme of sustainability
to be agreed which i think would just be
succinct wouldn't it
would that satisfy everybody would would
the proposer and the second to be happy
with that possibly yeah
um what i think councilor madison is
inferring is that we do have a fairly
standard condition about seeking details
of sustainability measures um
for us to consider we can apply that in
this case there's fairly consistency on
that basis if if obviously the uh right
we've got that on there
in a second sorry john sorry yeah
yeah all i wanted to say was that the um
i
that understand this is a case where we
might refer the applicants of mppf 148
150
taking the best use of the land
reserve matters have picked that bid up
thanks right proposer and the seconder
you have spoken but i would just like to
say
you're happy with with that um but from
personally from here
i mean i hear what the ward member and
the parish council have said and i can
understand it and the difficulties that
we've all got and i've read the late
papers and i've had them previously by
email
these villages are expanding and they
want to expand in a slow and and
appropriate way
and i absolutely hear them
we're all
suffering from it
and there have been a lot of
developments here
the applicant has reduced the numbers
down which is encouraging so they have
listened
but i do actually like the amount of
green space that would be appearing on
here and the size of the gardens
and so um you know i'm i'm sort of glad
that councillor humphreys asked that
this plan remain as is
so
thank you very much all those in favor
please vote
one two three four five six seven and
councillor um carter
yeah so it is unanimous thank you very
much
i think i'm sorry for those people who
are waiting but i really think we should
have a break now i mean it is
um two o'clock i'm sure you've missed
the canteen but um
you know i i think if you can find some
sort of refreshment
um half an hour i think is sufficient
isn't it because i think the canteen is
closed i'm sorry
we'd better start now so although we're
repleted were depleted so we have a
lesser community with us this afternoon
so without further ado page 449
stradbroken laxfield um harry goodridge
if you'd like to present the case thank
you
thank you chair so here we have an
application for the erection of one
dwelling following the demolition of
existing barns
or an existing barn sorry there is a
previous class q approval on the site
but cannot be implemented
so the site is located in lax field
is outside the segment boundary and as
such is considered countryside however
with the class queue already being
established the location is viable
so the site is located within a triple
si impact risk zone and a public
right-of-way runs across the front of
the site and heading out to the east
so obviously here we have an aerial map
with the site in its immediate context
as well as a site in the wider context
with blacks field being this out towards
the west
sorry
yeah so like i said lax field is
identified as a primary village within
the core strategy so i see within policy
cs1 that dictates that the parish is
capable of limited growth
uh the site can be identified as the
small orange dot
right in the center of the map just
there where the little pointer is now
is
roughly 0.6 miles from the settlement
boundary of lex field
so here we have the proposed block plan
showing the proposed dwelling
it is smaller than the previously
approved class q
by 16.18 meters squared
and however it does involve a small
increase in the ridge height
so also we have some existing plans
obviously showing the
the two
barns together
and the small cheese room just on the
end there
as did on the floor plan again it's just
the existing plans with the cheese room
and then these the bays coming through
the barns
and like i said more elevations just
flicking through them now so here we
have the proposed elevation plans and
elevations obviously
the building is retaining
an agricultural appearance it is single
story and the materials are consistent
with that of an agricultural building
and as i said previously the ridge
height is slightly increased
from the current building
under this application
so it is three to four bedrooms proposed
with a study having the potential to
become a bedroom
there is adequate parking on the site to
the west just after the access
and part of the existing cheese rooms is
to be demolished to offer a sense of
separation between the two plots
and it's just more of a close-up showing
all the
proposed elevations
and now we're just into some sight
photos
so obviously this is where roughly the
existing area for parking will be the
access is just off screen
to the left there
these are just obviously the existing
barns which would be to remove which are
to be removed under this application
that is currently the cheese rooms which
is partially
to be demolished to offer some
separation
the that's the site from the existing
access for the neighboring property to
the west
we have the existing track which the
access forms off of that and the
recommendation is for approval with
conditions detailed within the officers
report
thank you for that does anyone have any
questions for the officer
no
right thank you for that um well we
don't have um anyone from the parish
council objector or supporter or
the applicant either
so we just have councillor
flatman um
i totally support the application
it's another dwelling in keeping with
the environment
there is a
pathway to the village via a grass verge
which is very well kept up to the corner
farm you can then take a footpath down
behind the allotments into the village
or you have the choice of coming down
towards lower grove cottage going across
the fields on the footpath and come in
the village the other way so there is
footwear
i'm all for this it's it's um already
passed as predic permitted development
it's for a young couple living with
parents at the moment using an already
um site and i think it's in keeping the
way they've designed it so
totally support
thank you for that counselor does
anybody have any questions uh for the
counsellor
um i just have a question actually for
harry can you just show us the access
again to make sure we can
see the
access
please so the access is just off this
track here and it will come in off the
left
and is it shared with anybody or is it
no it will be a private access for that
property only the track i believe is
shared with the farm yard
here just behind these trees however
there is an off axis there which would
just be private for their property and
what sort of surfacing would they be
putting on that bit
we don't have any details currently or
the the actual access onto the site
sorry yeah
so obviously we would expect it to be a
bound material within five meters of the
highway obviously just comes under the
conditions which is no unbound materials
within five minutes of the highway
that's so suitable and it's not going to
end up like a quagmire
right thank you for that
right anyone else got any questions or
who's going to start the debate
councillor carter thank you
i just moved to um i don't see any
reason to object to his proposal it
seems
well
suited um as a point before it's going
to be for a young couple moving and
moving to the air it's currently being
used so i personally moved to propose to
to make a strange noise into her face
but no opposed to
propose to accept the uh
recommendation
councillor um
gaston sorry for the names
thank you chair i'm happy to second that
i i can't see any issues with this at
all and i am
i the um award counselor with her
superior knowledge to the situation um
is that's a that's a big factor that
yeah happy to second
thank you very much does anyone else
wish to speak oh yes councillor matheson
yeah i i wondered um
if if given that it's basically sort of
a non-sustainable location um about the
sustainability whether any more can be
achieved i suspect not um but possibly a
condition for reuse of materials which
the i think the parish has actually
reasonably enough alluded to
um
that um you know
there was no mention of sustainability
in the application
i think at least we could ask for reuse
of some of the materials
i would ask the proposer and the
seconder whether they want anything
added to their um proposal in seconds
so obviously that's the the closest
photo realistically showing all the
barns in their context obviously the
cheese rooms is afar
the cheese room
is far newer and as such the
and there's not much of that it doesn't
look like there's anything worth
rescuing to me
counselor casting do you want to i
wouldn't want to um
limit their ability to build a nice
functional modern efficient house by
using old materials also by using new
wooden materials they'll be locking up
carbon for decades and decades so um i'm
quite happy to not add anything any
conditions to that and councillor carter
same right okay so councillor warboys
wants to speak
sorry i just thought i'd speak in favor
i think retaining the
form of the agricultural buildings would
be better than
the the fallback position which is a i
think a new build
no this is this is the new build and the
full back position is to build what
you've got there the shed you know and
sort of restore it yeah yeah that's
where we are
on this one sometimes it happens the
other way and some of the ones we've had
still have proven i think so
okay all those in favor please vote
councillor warboys are you joining us
are you in favor of this
yes
and councillor norris i think we are
unanimous thank you very much everybody
thank you councillor
and now
john is in the driving seat for us never
having done this before
it's been a while
so let's let's see what the presentation
brings us today thank you
thank you uh thank you members i've i've
been asked to represent uh this final
item
to you this is a reserve matters
application
i'm a little rough in terms of
presentation so bear with me um so
there's a reserve matters application
the principal is already decided
by bring up the site we are dealing with
um
i'll start getting apologies hang on
look at my pages here
so the number of dwellings is 64.
this has been decided in principle with
the outline
before
we have all matters in terms of the 106
that includes affordable housing mix and
any other contributions have all been
decided
the existing future infrastructure
including buses and schools to serve the
development is not material to the
reserve matters at hand
access is also
been decided at outline stage
and
also this this matters is a little
unusual because
unlike other
sort of similar things we have actually
got layout that is also decided under
the outline application
so if i go through our plans here this
is the site
the aerial photographs this is the site
in terms of the constraints plan
the shaded buildings to the south of the
plan are listed buildings but there's
none immediately adjacent to this site
it is opposite what was the school site
this was the layout therefore approved
under the outline permission for uh this
night off
of wireless road
um for the number of houses that are now
being put forward as a reserve matters
but so what we have here is a fixed
layout so we have to deal with the
layout that was provided at this point
so we turned to the reserve matters
unsurprisingly the layout is similar
to that approved outline
so this leaves us with the arrangement
of the houses on the ground already
decided and the space between them
essentially already decided
so this is effectively a very simple
application
the application is for the appearance
landscaping and scale
of the dwellings already approved
so landscaping i admit is perhaps not as
simple as it should be as there is an
overlap with the outline
we have it conditioned in terms of the
outline as conditions of landscaping as
well as being a reserve matters
point to as well but the outline is
included in your papers in the bundle
so what we're looking at is what these
buildings look like
and
their scale so their size
and i'm going to just generally run
through these very quickly because they
are in your papers
they are two-story properties for the
most part there are five bungalows such
as that one
on the side
and i'm literally just going to click
through these uh because these will be
your papers
and you would have looked through these
just to give an overall there are street
elevations included
as indicated on the plan
where these have been taken from just
give you an idea of the mix and range of
properties
being proposed
and we have the landscape plan
that indicates
where the landscaping will be filling in
the gaps between the houses and their
layout already decided
essentially
the layout continues to be
based around the village green concept
which is in the center
and we also have an attenuation basin to
the
left hand side of the screen
which is all part of the layout that was
agreed
so it just follows that
photographs
some of these have been taken from the
previous outline application
it's a bit difficult to give us a sense
of the site as it is a field
and there's no getting away from that
this is what we have agreed for
development
so these are the various boundaries
they're all very very similar
and that leaves us with the proposal uh
in terms of the
layout but of course
essentially what we're dealing with here
is the appearance of scale of the
buildings with the landscaping
and we'll just leave it on there for the
moment
so we have five bungalows a range of
houses
including flats and we have in terms of
appearance
the design of the dwellings are
considered to be acceptable there's a
good mix of materials and standard
features
plans also show electric charging points
we also have hedgehog friendly fencing
as well the final details of the
hedgehog friendly fencing we have
conditioned because there's a little bit
of debate about making sure we're
getting it in the right place so we have
conditioned that to make sure we have
that agreed
um
just given what the ecology has
told us um the mix of housing has not
been secured at outline stage in this
case so it can't be looked at now
despite
uh the council's changing approach to
look at the mix of market housing
and this will be something we do in
future outline applications but in this
one we don't have control over the
actual mix of housing
a scale is predominantly two-story but
not excessive
and suitable given the character of the
area
given the limitation of the layout
already agreed
with fixed back to back and other
distances
officers have sought during the course
of the application to reorientate some
of the dwellings to reduce the
significance of overlooking
picking up on third party comments
received
but there will be some degree of
overlooking to existing
properties
the properties have changed to bungalows
to reduce that as well i don't know if
my colleague can point
particularly uh just for me or reach
over you just go to the right a bit
right
and up
up to the two the two in the middle
there just down a bit
okay so those two are bungalows and the
bungalows are also along the uh road
frontage to the north as well those
three there
um the attenua the attenuation basin if
you would see within your papers is not
what the county council would want to
see and they are maintaining a standard
holding objection on that basis
but as layout has been fixed we cannot
now go back and redesign or change the
area of it
so we have been talking to the county
over this issue a number of times and
while we appreciate the county have
moved forward in their guidance we have
to deal with the
outline that has been agreed here and
the reserve matters is appearance and
scale and landscaping not the
attenuation basin
so on that basis we have sought to
secure as much landscaping as possible
for the attenuation-based scenario
especially
without compromising its ability to
function or have
any particular maintenance issues
long-term of course we have to strike a
balance
we have ensured there's no public access
to any part of the attenuation basin
and perhaps on this basis we've actually
improved the ecology value of that area
on that basis
landscaping is somewhat tied to layout
already approved so the landscaping
details provided fall in line with the
layout and the areas available for
landscaping as expected and determined
by the outline
this application is a good example of a
development approved outline outline
that has followed through to the reserve
matters with little change in approach
and in accordance with the conditions
and agreement set at that time and on
that basis the recommendation is
approved
thank you very much does anyone have any
questions for the officer please
counselor norris it's just a small point
i didn't quite catch what the issue was
with the attenuation basin
so the attenuation basin as i understand
for my offices and county is a bit
deeper than that they would want it to
be it's not
as shallow as they want it and there is
other elements of the subsystem that
that they they they they've grappled
with but ultimately
it's it's a successful scheme don't get
me wrong it will do functionally what it
needs to do
it's just it's just that they
yeah it's a little bit deeper
so it it will not be a public accessible
area
the intention going forward um and i
know new guidance is coming out at the
end of this month and beyond is that
these do have a proper dual purpose in
terms of dealing with drainage but also
be able to be a functional open space as
well
and the county have been evolving
towards that very very slowly in this
case there's nothing we can do because
the layout of all the houses is set so
the space we have available just can't
be manipulated any further so this is
the position we're in but there is
nothing functionally wrong with the uh
scheme before us in terms of its
function
just appearance is perhaps not quite
where we wanted it to be but there's
nothing we can do about that at this
stage it's just too late
and counts are there any members of the
committee that want any further question
because i know councillor mellon wants
to ask a question
yes please thank you chair um it's just
a one of the clarification on the
electric vehicle charging points is
there
one on each house or just a number of
them
um
i'm not case officer so i presume it was
one per house on the plans they should
be they're indicated on the plans
looking at the outline
though the outline i don't think
specifically secures them so
it's what the applicant has offered
we can perhaps ask the applicant in a
moment
so we now move on
to
phil kobold who's going to
present on behalf of the applicant if
you would please
and before you start um i suppose we can
do it first ways off you can ask that
first or we can ask later
do you know about the electric charging
points has that been agreed
it's not a requirement under the outline
planning commission but as i understand
it it has a requirement yeah
there will be one for each property
thank you that just starts you for ten
right okay off you go with your three
minutes if you would please thank you
very much as you've heard this
application site already benefits from
outline permission for 64 dwellings
and as john has said that outline
permission approved the access and the
layout of the development and therefore
this reserve matters submission is
confined to the consideration of the
appearance and scale of the dwellings
together with the details of the
landscaping
as you've seen from the slides these are
high quality designs and the scale and
appearance of the dwellings follows the
suffolk vernacular and incorporates the
use of traditional materials
you'll see from the report that the
requirements of all of the technical
consulties have have been complied with
or were complied with at the outline
stage or can be addressed by the
conditions on the outline planning
permission
in response to the comments from backton
and wyverson parish councils the scheme
has been carefully designed to respect
the amenity of neighbouring properties
in adjacent earlsbrook
the new properties closest to the common
boundary are bungalows and where
two-story dwellings are proposed they
exceed the minimum back-to-back
distances in the suffolk design kind and
or they have no first floor windows in
the facing elevations so there'll be no
material loss of amenity
the amount of public open space accords
with your relevant policies and as john
has said that was also approved as part
of the layout under the outline planning
permission this is also the case with
the amount of car parking which occurs
with your adopted standards
wyverson parish council have objected to
the flats however the ten flats are the
affordable homes which are designed to
meet an identified need and to comply
with the affordable housing requirement
attached to the section 106 on the
outline permission
paris council's comments relating to
access traffic generation bus services
and local employment opportunities are
all matters which were taken into
account at the outline stage they are
not relevant to the details for you now
to consider
in summary this is a high quality scheme
which will deliver 64 homes including 22
affordable homes
delivery the delivery of these dwellings
will strengthen and improve the
viability of local services in the
village and will help to ensure the
council maintains its five-year housing
land supply thank you
[Applause]
thank you um do you know if you were
given permission when this would
commence
um i think it's likely that it'll
commence you know in in the near future
obviously there'll be other works to be
done but uh
yeah but anyway it's proposed that as
soon as the relevant if if
members are minded too as soon as the
proposed uh legal side is fitted as soon
as all the highway agreements are
resolved yes okay that's right right
that was just a question for me does
anyone else have any questions no
thank you very much did you have a
question no you couldn't then it's over
to you
thank you very much if you'd like to
return to your seat
and we now have councillor mellon who
will tell us about the location etc and
what he's
come up with
thank you chair um
i won't detain members of the committee
much longer
i do have to tell you that there are
several things about this application
that i don't like uh however i do have
to acknowledge that the difficult and
controversial parts of the development
have already been decided
with the initial permission and then
therefore not up for discussion today
this development is one of several large
developments in baton which gained
permission at a time when the council
was unable to demonstrate a five-year
land supply and as such
i wonder whether the detail of the
scheme received as much scrutiny as it
might do today anyway that's before my
time as councillor backton um so what
can i say about this site it's a
greenfield site on the edge of the
village it's agricultural land albeit a
field which has been unused for at least
a decade
in its favor the site is close to the
shop the pub it's within walking
distance of the primary school and our
doctor's surgery
and if and when a new primary school is
built on the old middle school site this
development will be
directly across the road from it
although we now have a much reduced bus
service essentially a minibus once a day
in each direction it does pass directly
along widerton road and i hope that a
new request stop will be established at
the entrance to this development
and that are
over time a decent service will be
re-established
turning to the negative as both bacton
and wives and parish councils have
stated this is a very dense development
its style feels more urban
than rural in page 307 5.1
uh states that the spacing between
dwelling dwellings is not overly
generous i mean you're not kidding
this really is a dense development
however i accept that the density has
already been determined is not up for
further discussion today
i do have concerns about road safety
the two main entrances to the
development are fine but the third
entrance the smaller one into the small
coast close called the drive
is right on the apex of a bend in the
road and i think it will prove
problematic for vehicles exiting onto
the highway
but again not up for discussion today
as you've seen in the bundle uh flood
and water management continue to have a
holding objection
but again that part of the application
has already been determined i'm very
grateful to the officer
sarah scott for the very useful
discussions we've had about this
application over several months
i'm particularly pleased that
negotiations with a developer have
resulted in plots nine and ten being
reduced to single story dwellings hence
addressing
largely the concerns about overlooking
from residents of earlsbrook
i have no particular comment to make
either positive or negative on the
appearance of the development it would
appear to be typical of many new
developments across the district and the
landscaping plan seems to be detailed
and adequate
in terms of the sustainability of the
development um given the prime
minister's statement yesterday on
phasing out petrol and diesel cars
by 2035 i'm pleased to hear that
all dwellings will be
having electric vehicle charging points
installed
i would like to see as proposed by our
environmental management officer on page
384 of the bundle that a condition is
put in place that requests a
sustainability and energy strategy prior
to commencement
in conclusion as i represent the two
villages who are opposed to this
development i cannot speak in favor of
it however the principle and much of the
detail has already been determined and
therefore i simply ask that the concerns
i have outlined be taken into
consideration thank you
thank you very much that's very clear
thank you does anyone have any questions
for the ward member
no
thank you very much indeed right in that
case then we are now open to debate
who wants to kick off
go on then counselor captain
[Music]
so most of the heavy lifting's been done
with this application um it's there's um
i don't i don't see any reason to oppose
the this design i think the electric
charging points
um that that's a really good thing for
me it's um it's good to equip them like
that
the um
i'll be interested to see the benefit of
an attenuation basin that people can't
walk dogs around and they're just left
to nature because um
should this um get approval
i i quite i'd be very interested in that
because um
normally um that that's got the
potential to provide a good um
ecological um environment with without
interference i am
so um
i
i don't know if there's going to be a
huge amount of debate but i'd
like to propose that we approve this um
these reserve matters
at this point and
wait to
hear from the other councillors
and that's that's
a very good point actually and there
james because
i think the applicant or the developer
will know that i know very well of an
attenuation pong not far from me
um and it
did become extremely overgrown and there
was a bit of a fence around it and it
all fell down and it didn't really quite
hit the button
so i hope this will be much more
improved
but
it's safety is the first thing i would
think
so if it's not open to the public then
safety is is the important thing
so thank you for um proposing it and
i think you mentioned something about
somebody mentioned about sustainability
is that the same thing that we put on
the other one that you might want to add
on to this one no is it different we
can't add it here no we can't add it
here okay
oh right appearance only can't do
anything about that okay
um councillors who who else would like
to speak on this matter
i mean if you wouldn't i'm quite happy
to second it
but i don't like doing that from the
chair but i will second it from the
chair while people think about if they
wish to speak
thank you councillor carter if you don't
wish to settle that from a chair i'll
happily second it from
[Laughter]
um it's just
you know if you want to speak on the
matter now is your time
to to say something
anybody else wish to speak i mean i
think i sort of heard um from the ward
member that and the parish council they
didn't like the
um
the flats but um
they are sort of in here in the design
and everything and so i think
we've got homes for people which is
important
so anyone else want to say anything to
get us counselling yeah just to come
back on that i think it is a an
important
part of private house supply to have
these less
scarce
um
denser areas
obviously the flats um we we need that
provision
within mid suffolk so yeah i just agree
with what you're saying there
so on that basis if no one else wishes
to speak we've got proposer and a
seconder so all those in favor please
we are unanimous and thank you very much
for waiting sorry you had to get left to
the end but it was worth it
thank you thank you very much everybody
the meeting is are there any um
nothing else no site visits so we can
now close the meeting and thank you
everybody thank you